I'm not prepared for this thing.
I'm slinging gmods with a girl.
I'm trying to keep a good body in me.
Like we did in each one.
My face in the screen?
Yeah, it looks like the surfaces.
There we have it.
And this is also my cat.
The cat that we're using.
And this one is my dog.
My cat.
It's looking good.
It is looking good.
You didn't work in?
This is what you think, Borschti.
I'm just kidding.
Why am I a bruh?
It's an only bot lane, you know.
Hi!
Do you want to see where I still owns my fucking
unnamed seat collection?
Ray here!
I get to ruin all those samples that I took, so yeah, I spelt them all with my opnion samples, and I spelt them, so...
No, as a rule of thumb, the likelihood of me showing my face in the screen is very fucking high.
Am I gonna apologize? No.
I didn't really get much time to say oh, it's a clean Gmod with the girls.
So, we have this.
Hi mom, I can't get more than I'm good.
Your immersion is getting ruined, unfortunately.
As I said, the likelihood of a reflective surface showing my bald GI balls is pretty high, so if you don't want to acknowledge that I am a woman, then you are more than welcome to check out our screen.
This is not the screen for you.
We are opening.
Paladin's face in my barber.
Can you hear me?
Hoodie up.
Oh, you wanna put Hoodie up?
It's actually really smart.
Hold on a minute.
Women on the screen?
Green blanket.
What does that mean?
If I can even get into the spot.
So, I have this as well, which we're gonna put away the ones we get in the correct order.
Have a face mask.
I don't have one.
I'm having a show so the microphone picks me up because the microphone is now right here.
Yeah.
I just thought we'd do some gambler.
Go gambling.
Aw, dang it.
The real gambler was trying to open the box to see if he knew.
Do you think?
This is so reflective of that's the way to happen.
I mean, to be honest.
To be honest, I just look like a depressed fucking, you know, golf ad, really.
Not that I am depressed.
It's just I'm depressed.
No, I'm not depressed.
No, that's what I'm trying to say.
I'm not depressed.
Just, I look depressed on first.
Oh, shame you.
Oh, what's going on?
Now hold on a minute.
The leg.
Yeah, pulling.
Maybe the real gambler was the one you were looking for.
I am just in this to relive what I want in my childhood.
I cannot miss the shame of things.
I'm actually in my time.
What is this?
This thing?
Oh, let's see then.
And this is the coin flip.
This one is the coin flip.
There's the two.
Where's the refling card?
I will get it though.
Oh, this is like something I can make.
Oh, it's like I thought it was metal.
Classbook.
TCG car truck simulators came out by the way.
Hold on.
Let me recalibrate.
I'm going to do it.
So, do you know how to do it?
You step on it.
I may as well go some higher.
Yes, unfortunately.
Well, not unfortunately.
I was playing Gmod.
Where's the girl?
So, I didn't have much time to set this up.
So, I'm a bit...
Can you tell I've never opened a Pokemon box before?
What am I trying to achieve?
Okay, we have...
Holy shitele.
We have basic decks.
I assume this is not the gambler.
Oh my god, shame you.
So, this isn't the gambler.
I assume these big pre-made stacks are decks, not gambler.
And then it comes with its own pocket.
So, if we get a really good card,
it comes with its own pocket of notes.
And then...
So, if we get good cards, we'll put them in there.
And then we've got...
What is that? Open five?
Any Pokemon enthusiasts know what this is called?
The big stack is all energy cards?
Are you serious?
Why would they give you that?
I don't know why.
It's a deck to Vador.
No.
Look at you, you little nerd.
Answered all our questions.
Okay, I assume the gambler is these.
This is what the gambler is.
Oh, sorry. Let me spread it for you.
All name gambler.
This is why we're here.
This is the money shop, people.
The money shop.
The gambler.
Right, what one do you want first?
Let's spread it.
Excuse my seat collection.
What have we got?
God, I don't even recognise half of these Pokemon.
Oh, God, I should have picked an old school pack.
There's Pikachu.
There's a pink thing.
There's a blue thing.
There's a whale.
What one do you want?
Show me the card.
Why are they so big?
Why are they so big in your hands?
That's a booster pack in your hand.
You want the pink one?
I'll give you the pink one.
I think there might be a code inside.
So if you play the online game, sure.
You can grab the code.
There's only the difference to me.
Tinkerton.
Put your phone.
It's just tiny hands.
Thank you for this set.
Dainan.
M&S.
Oh, God.
Hold on.
Did we think about the real challenge about this stream?
Opening the pack?
Or literally opening them?
I can't do that.
Am I going to need scissors?
What the hell?
Are these factories?
Is this not for children?
Um...
I just...
Bruh, hold on.
I'm getting confused.
I'm talking to the show now.
I'm not...
You were playing with me saying that.
So I'm going to get you ready to take over the stream.
Okay, first quiz.
Obtain...
the card opener.
Look, you remember when I said the nail glue one
and I needed scissors?
The nail glue got stuck to the scissors.
Ladrian.
Thank you for the extended membership two months.
Our having small hands is great.
Make other things bigger.
Right, we're going to make sure
we're not actually only cutting the top of the card.
So as you can see, I'm using my finger as a gaze.
Is that the result we wanted?
Seeing those Pokemon packs
and knowing the size of them,
you really have tiny, adorable hands.
They look massive in your hands.
More than you know.
Whatever Brian is saying, I do not endorse.
Right, first gamble.
Okay, this is the code.
If you're a gamer online,
note yourself out.
If you want to focus,
so the QR codes are rich and durable.
There you go.
There you go again.
Right, I didn't even go.
Seeing those Pokemon packs
and knowing the size of them,
you really have tiny, adorable hands.
They look massive.
I'm actually just so big.
Is this the one where it's like
put two from the back to the front
and then, I don't know,
open the pack,
fill the code in one card to the front.
This one to the front.
Okay.
Are you ready?
Oh yeah, I got an energy.
I'm so excited.
You got elephants.
No, you need to focus webcam.
Please.
We're gambling.
Thank you.
What the fuck is that?
That's not technical.
Alright, I should have went old school with this.
I should have went old school.
Leechonk.
Leechonk, onk, onk, onk.
Okay.
Ooh, I like ganga.
I like you.
I like that pun.
You got technic on the tree.
Crisis punch.
It's emotional speed.
You got...
What does that do?
Dash bun?
Wait, is this the part?
Hold on.
Wait, can I do this thing?
Can I do this thing that all the streamers do
when they get something like a really good pool?
Is it a good pool?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
There's one good card in this pack.
Oh!
What does that mean?
Oh, oh, oh.
Right.
He's shining, so we're going to...
We are going to night him
with one of these,
of the Static Force on his leg.
We're going to have to put him in here.
You go.
What is you?
I told the crew.
So it's a tentacle, but not a tentacle.
Don't be distracted.
It's not a tentacle, but not a tentacle.
Why should I throw it into the camera?
Because I don't know if it's a tentacle.
We just slayed it in,
and then we can get a perfect breed
when we sell this.
Oh yeah.
We just slayed it in.
You know you guys still have another couple of irons
to do when you're still on 2D?
I don't know.
It's such a good one.
It's just a little tentacle.
You can...
You can freak it out if you get a special artwork card.
I'm going to put him
to the side again.
And we got Haunter!
Ah!
We got Holo!
Look at that.
Mmm.
Let's go down blue.
Do I put a Holo
in the shiny pocket as well?
Or is this a reverse?
Haunter and Gengar in sameSceneHackDane.
How appropriate that first two could be.
For the tentacles.
Is this pre-recorded?
Exactly.
That put in a wee aslonee punch.
I bet it's Husky and Snacky.
You're winning?
Okay, good.
I'm going to put all my wee shins
in these specials.
There's like tons of these anyway.
I don't know.
So I'll put our pools so far that are good here and then the regular one, we're going
to numeric the deck and then we're going to put it away in the binder the correct way.
Okay pick a card, any card, any pack of yours.
We did just do a tincture tin pack, so maybe we'll do Pikachu?
Pikachu has three, wait there's so many left, yeah this is, that was the first pack that
we opened, we've only opened one pack so far, right, right open, open, right as I said the
cards are at the bottom, my finger is a guide to where the cards start, so I literally can't
put into them, it's not possible, I've seen a few handcams like put into the pack and I'm
like why are you putting into it so willy nilly, believe, believe, open cumin, we don't say
open sesame around these parts, oh no, oh no, two cards stayed in, I don't know what the
order is, order, okay you ready for your card if you play the online game, oh yeah,
look at that, get that code in, get that holographic in the game, mmm yeah, that's great, you deserve
it, right, unfortunately I messed up the opening so I don't know if this truly is where it belongs,
so I'm going to put two in front, are you ready, boom, oh, well that worked out rather well,
that doesn't seem to me, it's the start of the day, I don't know, how was I doing that, like this, yeah
I saw something shady, I don't know what it is, but I see it, close, close,
this is probably the hardest move, shuffle them for a surprise, I opened them wrong, can you
please focus, oh I was going to get a model based after her, she has a lot of good
art or software, hello what so, oh I like that, is that a indie electric flying,
it's truly good, Ion is an annoying card, oh God guard of hours, pre-evolution,
when you've got the fairing whip, I spent 40 instead of, Varun, Varun, and then, and then I'm trembling,
oh, oh my God actually, I'm happy about that card, oh my God, I'm like so happy, it's guard of hour,
oh I'm actually happy about that, I'm not even kidding, I'm actually happy, look, oh she's pushing
and yes guard of hours is she, no I will not be taking any comments,
right, guard of hour getting here, Scottish guard of hour cosplay wins right now,
oh my gosh, so so far we have guard of hour, little kinds of in the booger, oh you can't really see
the shine on them in these, but they are shining from us, very slowly, so that's our hall so far,
there's an even more beautiful version of guard of hour in this pack, are these pre-selected cards,
am I celebrating over nothing, are these not Rambo, are these not Gambo,
and the four of them celebrating three, we've not done the wheel yet, or the purple one,
well I do eat, well chi chi a Scottish thing, right, this is a Scottish thing, don't judge me,
it bit dog shit, here if I need to see two, that's it, and then you pick this one,
that's when you do it, and the they are Gambo kids, okay, as you are my witness, the cards are
done there, she said dog shit, haven't heard that, takes a drag from a cigarette, haven't heard that
yet, normally eating any of them anymore, but we were a bit different around these cards,
right, let me grab all of the cards correctly this time, guard of hour, are you ready to study,
oh up there then, no please focus, you're working focus right away,
and then pick one from the back and put it to the front, and then watch,
why don't you put the energy on the back, that sniff is so low, because you have flashback,
yeah, we already got you,
oh I've missed that one, mass chip, is it a Matthew, is it a Mickey,
oh we got baby rolls, we have the rolls generation, oh man, hey I on Gary here, we already got you,
get out, we already got you too, how are we getting duplicates, we're in pack three,
and we're getting duplicates, come on, whatever you ate, nasty, right, I like nasty,
I mean you're different, I love it, what's his name, what's trio, are you squidding me right now,
I don't know, I'm pretty sure it's them,
let me put them away, gently put them in the pocket, and then I'll see what Brian's saying to me,
are you squidding me right now, are you squidding me right now, a little bit more every day,
thank you for his phrases, thank you, I love Scotland a little bit more every day,
thankful for its phrases and you, oh wait what, oh my god I'm going crazy, oh well that's what we
wanted anyway, and then we got this guy, eggs with people, and he's a huge basic, is it, how
is the ranking, it's like shiny reverse hollow, what's the ranking, you're gonna have to tell me,
again I'm sorry but I'm doing this for male attention, I'm getting no, I'm getting no enjoyment,
no valence, no nothing sir, I've got two shiny hollows right, hold on let me check,
because I can't hear and I've got my headset on, thank you lord of scorns for the tip and thank you,
order Ling Mummy, why did, why did you order this ordered box, I would like to order them,
yeah, yeah, wrap it up, wrap it up, you're getting spanky, these are our whole,
we've got decent ones so far,
it's okay mummy, we'll give you all the attention, oh my god attention,
okay we've not opened up a wheel, so we'll do any mini mini mini more, catch the title,
if this wheel lets it go, mini mini mini more, wheel pain, wheel pain,
and then, well again fingers the gaze, so no cards are gonna get cut, no cards were cut,
no cards were cut in the making of this, strong,
see, not many awards, almost, almost, let's go wheeling, oh dang it, oh dang,
I'm a wheel of the beach variety, oh hell yeah,
that's also going on before we open the cards again,
okay, ready, steady, go,
one card to the front,
do you think you'll play the online game, I might give it a shot, I don't see why not,
can I do gen 3 only, oh my god a war card, I'm so excited,
oh no more, I know no more, I know no more, I love you, no more in camel rucks,
oh no you didn't see that, who's fucking doing that, terrible,
terrible, I don't know who the streamer thinks they are,
oh you're in my game too, you're in pokemon ruby, so I know you,
gen gar, nice to see you again buddy, but how are we getting duplicates in the
a nest ball, well that's a good sign, oh hold on,
I thought that was something under the nest ball,
uh swuba, I've played this den as well, I think that's pokemon black,
okay I'm happy with a little bit of gold, I'm gonna put you to the safe
and then we've got rate, Iona, how about you, Iona up to and give it a break, stop
showing up, that's the third pack now, and then a researcher,
not fast, not fast, not fast, but we'll still put them away in packets,
really special packets, is it a shiny, I mean is it called a reversal thing because it's a
mummy, wait, hold on I'm not actually seeing this again,
oh wow, that's actually quite a unique one if your death is completely terrible,
uh so when are we doing streams tonight pokemon, um right now I think,
okay only five more gambas to go, what would you like,
the streamers may be questioning if I'm sober or not, what does that mean,
which gen is she from, I think seven maybe,
your wish, my command, what's up big abby, I'm ash from pallet town
and you're gonna be my new buddy, we're gonna be together forever,
what, no, Pikachu, I'm not ditching you for guard of hour, I just need some personal time,
you know, to train her of course, we're in gen nine, relax, relax, we need to rough up,
that's the code, what is, holy shit that's ash's voice, no, wait yes actually I'm the real ash
from ash pallet town, the hit video game series pallet town, energy, see I'm never unhappy seeing
muster boys, I love muster boys, oh mr moe, nice to meet you, mom what are you doing with mr moe,
you're making some weird noises last night, noobat is so cute and then his evolution it turns ugly,
he's wrappedy, he's in put one black, he's found in the desert with one black,
a electrical generator, what was mr. mom doing, I don't know, threw back the tea,
Then we have a backpack. Oh my gosh, I'm so excited for the backpack. Get- get those legs out of here. You belong in the war. I don't care what they've done to your evolution line, get back in the war.
I didn't know Mr. Mime could wrestle with your mom. That's so cool.
Oh my god. Right, I take it back. Neubat's evolution is kind of fucking cool. Hold on a minute. Is that- is that Shani? Is that Shani Hollow?
Is that Neubat? That's not Neubat's original look. See, Neubat's purple. Oh my gosh.
Oh, is that normal? Is it not called Neubat?
It's called Neubat. Yeah, first one's called Neubat. Yeah, I'll show you Neubat.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe it. I pulled the fucking Shani. What? You mean there's a higher chance rate that every packet has something Shani in it?
No, don't tell me such things. I want to see Neubat turn it- it involves into Neubat.
What is the po-ka-dex of toy school and the- and the thingy? Hearing Ash cursing is so funny.
What the fuck are you talking about? What are you doing? Pikachu, for fuck's sake. Just kill the leader.
Why are you using Quick Attack? That's a normal type move. It's a fucking ghost type you're against. What are you playing at?
Basically, have I imagined how Ash would be? Si, I wish women were real. Takes a drag from a cigarette. I wish women were real.
I'm fake. I'm- remember, I'm doing this for Neal, okay? Ask her if I just snipped a card. I'm gonna cry. Did I? Did I just do that?
Hold on a minute, Ash. You're on the back burner, son. I'm raging. Did I just snipped a card?
Better not have. No, I've no- it's fine. I've no-
Ash, are you ready? Online players. There's that code and QR thing that you can do now. Yeah, you like that.
Did you go to pokemon.com slash bdm? Then you're not a real gamer. I like how the official lore is now. I've just done it now. There's no going back.
She is doing this because she got paid by the casino. I'm actually addicted to gambling. It's a real problem, but I hide it behind this board.
Oh, the results again. Magmar, playing the board. It's nice to have you.
Oh, are you the pre-evolution to that pastry looking dust? I can't- I know there's a generation that is in France. Is this French?
Is that French? Oh, not French. Are you French? Don't quit before you hit that jackpot. You already know it, baby.
Lantern. He's an evolution of the night. Clive. Congrats if your name's Clive.
Women's got- I'm reading this upside down, by the way. No, Jen's like this.
Where has it been?
What is it called?
Oh, maybe it's what it's called.
Cereluity.
I don't know what you are. You're a poison type?
The webcam ain't very good. You want it? Did we say it's good? Is it 16?
I didn't see that. I promise I didn't see that. Life's sucker. Oh, wow. It's like a fighting type.
I'm going to send the package.
Cereluity.
And then-
Are we happy?
I don't know. Are we happy?
I'll wait for your reaction. Special art? Good?
Good? Oh, hey! Hey! Must be streamer luck.
Streamer luck, streamer luck.
Oh, no! I made a cup of tea!
No!
No! It's fucking cold!
Whatcha say? I have no more milk, so I can't make another one.
Whatcha say?
No!
I'm going to try it.
No! Up for gore.
Okay, we're going to very gently put her away. So she's the Ash, 2.0.
So she just got a lighter voice than Ash. So if Ash is down here-
I need to try and raise it up here. Is this how she sounds?
I don't know. I haven't seen that anime, but you said she's kind of like a tomboy.
So, is that- She's a yandere? What's going on? What's going on?
What's going on?
Microwave the tea. Do not speak again for the next 10 seconds and think about the actions of your words.
Another one says microwave the tea! Are you mental?
Mmm, no. I thought I was kinky, but microwave and tea? Mmm, too far.
Okay, it's a game of three.
We've got three gambas. What's wrong with the microwave?
You didn't microwave tea, though. You can use the microwave as much as you want, but you want a cup of tea.
I'm not having that.
Your hit rate is- His box is really good. I've never seen that many hits before.
Streamer luck.
Another dodonzo.
This is dodonzo.
Okay, we have two more packs, and then we're going to alphabetize.
You have a tea addiction, a gamba addiction, a zeal.
They opened up that game that I played PCG Card Shop Simulator.
They've released it early, and I'm like, mmm, I want to play it now, but I must wait for stream.
I'm going to start fresh and then play through the game.
I'm going to hire you to work in my little card shop.
Oh!
Is this the card you're looking for?
Oh, it's not the card.
Oh, yeah? Check your force, then.
Exactly.
A warm-in oven.
I'm going to pour it in.
Tutu?
Lechonk, right here.
Sharked it.
What are you, a picnic?
Oh, wait, it looks like it's got a coconut mask on.
Oh, you're new.
Ker-let-oh-bet-oh-piss, clobber-piss.
Glob-clobber-piss? Any clobber-piss fans?
Dom-fam, we know Dom-fam because that's an ashes team.
Hey, that's my Dom-fam.
Ne-mo-nans-backpack.
Well, I don't know why she's lost it, but get it out of here
because we've already got this card.
Get it out of here.
Okay.
Oh, it's the evolution of the guy.
Hello.
You look like you're on the same team.
They're the same player, right?
It's a ground-type octagon?
Huh?
A ground-type octopus?
Uh...
No, they're feyin'.
Oh, feyin'? Okay, okay, okay.
That makes much more sense.
Sorry, this is brand, so my brain's like...
brand.
If it's brand, then it's brand.
Ooh, what are you?
Beth?
Beth, what?
Please, camera, I'm begging.
Little?
Why can't you see the upper skirt?
Ah!
Oh, sorry, it's the next card.
Hold on, hold on, hold, hold, don't get too exu-
It's the next card, okay?
It's the next card.
Ah!
Oh, my God, it's Meg Mortar!
It's the super-evolution!
Ah!
Oh, yeah, baby.
Oh, yeah, Mr. Krabs.
We got it.
Come on.
Yeah, look at that.
Volcanic Heat.
Volcanic Heat is 170 attack, hold on.
During your next turn, this Pokemon can't attack.
Oh, it's a build-up.
It's like Sunbeam.
It's a build-up attack.
Meg Mortar is an ugly basketball, isn't it?
Why did they make his lips like that?
His lips were not that big in the pre-evolution.
I know that for the fact.
I've seen what you look like when you're wee.
I've seen you when you're wee.
You're gonna be like growing up with any like that ugly.
So what's going on?
Pokemon and making cute little Pokemon's fucking ugly.
Challenge impossible-evolution.
Sorry, that wasn't even a sentence.
Bye-bye, thank you for hanging in.
Please don't worry, you can't hang.
This is a short stream today.
It's not- it's not mega-
uh, massive and finished in just a minute.
Let's be honest.
Is this a serious Pokemon opening?
No, I've never done it before.
I just always wanted to do it with my childhood wish.
Okay, it's between purple or yellow.
Pikachu and then.
I mean, it's not that much damage these days.
I have a card that goes to Jesus.
You want purple?
Short stream, next four hours.
Let's go!
Oh, and it's slow though.
No, I dealt with the script writers.
So, I had to, like, get my management to send on.
There's two people I picked.
And I'm, like, right.
So there's been a message.
As far as I'm aware, there's been emails,
but only two people emailed,
and there was, like, seventy-eight people wanting to write scripts.
So, mm-hmm.
Right, was there purple?
Was there purple one?
So, I was up dealing with that,
so I've not had much to do, so I'll go apologize.
And then we were playing G-Mod.
Emperor Zurus couldn't fucking connect!
I was raging!
Um, I don't know why she couldn't connect to Sheevee.
Sheevee was hosting four, and I was, like,
oh, is it because you were hosting it, Stormy?
No.
And we were, like, trying so hard,
but it just, it really could not get in.
Oh, no, I've done it.
Fuck, sorry.
I pulled it out wrong.
Oh, how?
I have one job.
I don't, I don't know what card it is.
I think it might be this one.
We're gonna do this.
If we get spoiled early, that's completely on me.
Yeah, we played offline.
It wasn't a stream, no.
And if we do end up streaming G-Mod,
unfortunately I can't stream it on my end
because the lag is too severe.
And I was, like, a magic trick.
Mm-hmm.
No, I did not expect that much of a response on the list, right?
Um...
I don't know.
My friend was, like,
oh, you've got that many spoken words, right?
Oh!
We can...
Right, no one saw that, no one saw that.
No one saw that, right, no one saw that.
Ooh, right, she's focused.
Faincon?
Is that your name?
A faincon?
No one saw that, no, don't laugh.
Don't laugh.
Are you gonna focus me?
There you go.
Faincon.
Energy.
Good.
Fancy.
Lapras.
Good.
Moonlit hell, all right.
Can't unwrap the finished numeral's evolution one
unless you've got mega-evolutioned and
you saw nothing.
Pinnacle is gen 2.
What?
I haven't recognized him at all.
Good luck on the first thing to you,
Primi.
Love you, darling, love you, Primi.
Ecstasy?
Okay, we've got ecstasy flying through.
Pikachu.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm so surprised we got this card!
Oh no!
What?
This didn't get spoiled a minute ago because
I messed up the order?
What?
No, what are you talking about?
Oh my god, celebrate!
Yay!
Wow, I never...
No, I never expect that either.
Only I could have messed that up without them.
Okay, we got one of them.
Each one.
Wait, did we get another one of them?
Hold on, I need to go through the special tile.
These cards are special.
Also, I've got a bone to pick for some of you reeflings.
What's going on?
Mummy needs to have a talk.
I've been getting a few marshmallows saying
you feel really bad when you interact with me
and you overthink and you think you're upset
and you're annoying me.
What's going on?
Why are you overthinking interacting with me?
What is going on?
Why are you scared to interrupt?
Everyone's like, I've had a couple of marshmallows
that are apologizing for interacting with me
because they feel bad about it.
And I'm like, what are you talking about?
The person that did the 9-11 joke.
They're like, I'm so sorry I didn't meet up today.
And I was like, no, I was getting a rise out of the joke
because I said it so fast that I didn't think it.
It was funny.
And then I got another one that was like,
I feel like you appreciate me.
And I'm like, I'm sorry, this one.
I thought I was doing good.
I thought I was doing alright.
You know, I've been in every day, having fun,
looking through all the good things that come.
We don't want to embarrass ourselves.
It's a view of the reasons I have got it.
Some got it.
Open and put them on card packs.
Right, this is the last pack, so make it count.
Brains until brain worms got hands.
Yeah, and normally I thought I was defeating the brain worms
before they could spawn in.
That card is 9 gigabytes.
Oh, you grabbed it?
It's because you're super shy and you like it a lot.
Oh, this one.
You must brain break us not to think.
Oh, well, if you put it that way.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yes.
You need your energy.
Shark a bit.
Right, for a fucking yambo?
How many cards are in this bag?
This is like...
Bruh, I've seen you.
Get over here.
Are you new here?
So many duplicates.
I know.
I know you're saying that I'm getting lucky with the pills,
but the duplicates...
Bruh, that's like the third or fourth time.
You don't have people who are like, I get addicted
and I just want to keep yamboing more.
I get so fucking annoyed that I spend money on this.
I'm like, mmm, you there or not?
You there?
Fucking shit that way.
How many backpacks does this bitch have?
I don't want to keep fucking buying more.
Chronic lurker hurt.
Here, can confirm I'm shy.
Oh, don't feel forced to talk if you don't want to talk.
So that's different.
You just want to lurk that time.
Artazone.
Ooh, Skipplin.
I don't know you, but it's nice to have you.
Is that mine?
Wait a minute.
Oh, you can have two and a thing.
Skipplin looks good.
What?
That was it.
Oh, he's shiny as well.
I'm fucking gambling again.
What the fuck was that?
That's fucking piss.
Right, I'm going to put the specials away
and then we're going to alphabetize.
We're going to number them.
It's shiny and a gender.
Skipplin is gender?
What?
Am I going to meant?
Right, I've not played the Gen 1 or 2 game.
I'm sorry.
I started at Ruby.
I started at Ruby and then I did 4 and 5
and then I couldn't do 6.
So I'm only similar.
You're wrestling.
That's me with the polka dots.
Horn good, yeah.
Horn region is my region.
The only reason, this sounds really bad,
but the only reason I remember horn region is my region
is because I'm horn me.
Like, I'm playing the horn me region.
That's what I remember.
These were our pools.
Let me just kind of zoom into it this way
because this is like...
This is harder than it looks.
Not that I'm saying any special applause for doing this, okay?
But this is not how I expected
to go.
I expected to...
I expected to hardly even know her.
My eyes, I'm sorry.
The noyvern is pretty cute.
I have to admit, noyvern is such a nice word to say,
like noyvern.
Like, it's a satisfying word to say noyvern.
Ah, noyvern.
Noyvern, noyvern.
I started at Gen 1.
So I got a special...
Wugtrio and Neymona.
A special art.
Rainworms go.
Mommy's love is here to stay.
Aw, thank you.
Hapsicum.gar for the extended membership.
Thank you.
I got a little...
We got guard of hour.
I'm really happy with guard of hour.
I think if I have to be biased,
noyvern and guard of hour
are my favorite tools.
Not... I'm not telling Sivirino.
Um, my fellow mercs.
I really like...
Noyvern has a lot of HP.
He's stacked out with HP.
260 as well.
It's just OP as well.
140, 140, 120 health.
Only 90 at that time.
No.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
You're so weak, you little baby.
Headbutt 30.
Undersea tunnel.
Flip three coins for each head.
Guard of top three cards of your point is dead.
Come here.
Black blood.
Thank you for the extended membership.
Sunnybell.
You can do more.
Two eggs is a full art shiny egg.
A full art trainer.
Two shinies in an art rare.
Pretty tall box.
There's so many Pokemon.
Play the TCG win.
Oh, I feel like I'm gonna make a fill on myself though.
I feel like I'm gonna make such a...
a guberino of myself.
Cause I don't know what we're gonna do.
I'll maybe need to research some videos.
I found a video game that I wanted to play for an ASMR.
Like pre-recorded ASMR.
Some people do that stuff when you do ASMR videos.
There's 1,025 Pokemon.
Okay, I recognize about 300.
Take your leave at...
Royce.
This is the bit where I don't really know how to progress.
And the reason for that...
Pre-recorded?
No, I pre-recorded ASMR stuff.
This is where I don't know how to progress, for the most part.
I want to numerically number them.
But I need to like place down...
like 1 to 10.
I don't even know how big this deck is.
Wait.
This deck is 91, not including the hidden.
Can you see that?
Oh, please do this.
It says this is card 39 out of 91,
not including the hidden.
So, I don't know if I should put them in the tiles for now.
Like that's the third tile.
This is 90, of course.
So what?
Like 1...
So let me back up a little bit.
So like 1, 2, 3, and then 9's down here.
This is 5, so that was over there.
50.
This is 71.
So like here in the 7, that's 6.
Do you know what I mean?
Is this the best way to do it?
And then I'll put it in the book at that way.
Back it up, yeah.
See, this is 4, so this would be at the start of the deck.
16, so that would be 0, 10, 4, 8, 8.
So yeah, there you go.
0, 10, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
And then specials will go right where my head is.
Let me make myself smaller.
Oh, let me make myself smaller.
Aw.
You're massive.
You like my socks?
Is this the comfy?
Yeah, I got them at the asylum.
Man, they released me.
I don't know why.
They just had another name.
Fuck this.
50?
Oh my god, look at them.
Concert and things like that.
The Griffey Gryffindor.
Well, you never had heads on a V2 Gryffindor before?
What's going on here?
That's 14.
51.
This is the best way I can see it in my head to do it.
Like the most efficient way when I'm putting them away.
That says 8.
6, 7, 8, 9 specials increases when that's through the balls.
I hear cracking.
What?
Wait, cracking in my mind?
Would you be the first?
I'd like to be the first, but you're here.
I do like cherries.
Do you like cherries?
6, 7.
1, 2.
What's the first 2?
It's the routine you're doing to me.
Oh, Panko is the first card in the 6.
They always start with grass-papes.
You can do grass-papes that much.
Fancy for you.
3, 4.
The rest, thank you for coming.
Remember, please enjoy the emotes.
I'm getting new emotes soon, I promise.
I'm waiting for an update with the emotes.
They're not really doing much.
And I've been waiting so well.
It's not above 50%.
Yeah, the specials seem to be at the end of the deck.
No, they would be kind of the 4.
2, 3, and 4.
What's my cherry? Can you help me find it?
No, no, no. I've picked the cherry.
You'll never get it back.
Hmm.
I've got to work now. Good luck and have fun.
Thank you.
As I said, it's a very short stream today.
Please do not be getting straddled in.
I assure you the only straddling is me.
Straddling for a paddling.
I do think I'll have Ace more tomorrow.
There'll be a new Ace more video.
My Patreon is also going to get an update.
I can either do a police officer,
do something to your P-Sport,
or I can do a different role play.
Take care, leave it.
The cherry, mine, thank you.
No, that is...
Chinnicle.
I love Chinnicle.
Right now, I'm mercy a little bit for some reason.
I don't know why I'm just like that adorable nature.
Flip a coin.
Is what I mentioned was useful.
It's only the cherry trigger.
Honestly!
I'm not going to be extra haunted,
which I'm not mad about. I don't mind haunted.
Iona, you can pop off.
We've had enough of you for quite some time.
I have to admit, was there...
Iona, we see you quite a lot,
and we're not really that fast to see you that much.
It was nice.
Well, it lasted.
I mean, it was through 8-6-6.
Then we were given them two.
Sonya, I'm begging you.
You only got a few more hours if you're the 2D weekend.
It's only a few more hours.
I should...
I either have a hands-cam video where I'm tapping on the girls.
It's just a rambling ASMR.
You guys seem to enjoy my rambling ASMR,
and because I don't have to write a script,
it doesn't need to be performed a certain way.
I don't mind making it.
Like, I'm playing a happy music now.
Seriously.
So it's like a rambling tapping on each...
It's like with my nails, with my fake nails.
I've got five days.
I'm happy my music.
The projector!
Two days left in this season.
Your rambling is really soothing.
Yes!
I'm glad because...
Not in a lazy way.
It means I have less work to do.
A lot of pressure is taken off where it's like...
You don't need to write a script because you know me.
I'm already behind.
How much energy cards do they give you?
Look at these.
Energy, energy.
And then they already gave me...
Here is this entire pack full.
Remember it.
That's how much I hate it.
I've already lost it.
What?
I'm getting fluff on me.
Don't look.
There's fluff on me.
They really stuff me so it's tiny.
I wonder...
Oh, that's the seven?
That would still be it, right?
Yeah.
Get my tails of it.
What's the one here?
What's the one?
That's a team.
That's 51...
49.
That's 69 brain loss.
And then her backpacks which are...
Plenty.
Nope.
Yeah, we do not need any more backpacks.
I assure you we are...
Hitting down for backpacks, really.
No.
No seriously.
We do not need any more.
Is that it?
And then we've already sorted through all the cards?
Oh well.
We are efficient.
You can call us reeflings many things.
We are efficient when we know what we're locking in.
Mummy, have my first.
Oh, we got your super cherry.
Your super cherry.
Thank you, big ol' boy.
For the super cherry.
It's May now.
You can't get it back.
I'm fine now.
Mummy, yappin' is like the news for old people can't live without it.
I think it is.
Thanks for having that Susan rambling in the backpacks.
Hey mama, just got here.
You can hear that.
I'm ecstatic to record ASMR about having just quiet myself down.
I submitted a sample script.
Will I receive any feedback if I wasn't chosen or if I was?
When you whisper...
Like it's quite damaging to your voice.
Which I'm used to now.
I'm used to my voice.
When I do ash from pallet town, this genuinely hurts my voice.
But I understand that it's going to be okay and it will heal up.
But whispering pain of death not only takes the men to meet as well.
So there's a lot of 20s.
What's going on?
It's all 20s.
Again 21.
78.
This was a very...
So we got rare cards.
But I will admit the repeats are killer in this deck.
That's it.
That's us already ready to adjust into the good.
Brian got ignored.
Oh sorry.
Hold on.
I can't.
I don't have my headset on.
I'm reading.
Look, you can even get a little football.
Yeah, you like that football.
I'm a ballerina.
Shilin.
Hey mom, I just got here.
How's the script for everything going?
I'm a lot curious.
I'm a bit disheartened for the script.
But we'll ever see any feedback if I was chosen or not.
When will I know?
So two people have been emailed.
We're waiting on them to send their response script.
And then we'll take it from there.
Thank you Shilin for the morning.
Can I say that?
Yeah, I do.
No, they've been emailed.
So only two people were emailed and there was like 76 applicants or something like that.
So please don't be like, oh my God.
Shilin.
Like, oh, I got debated.
I thought it was an unopened part.
Oh my God, I got excited there.
Yeah, third time.
Sorry Brian.
Brian got yaps out.
I'm sorry.
Do you want me to repeat it?
I can repeat it.
Hi mom, how are you?
I'll repeat it.
But yeah, look at that leg.
Look at that.
You see me tensing it up?
Right there.
Brian, your turn.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Hey mama, just got here.
How is the script writer thing going?
I'm a little curious but shy.
I submitted a sample script.
Will I receive any feedback if I wasn't chosen or if I was?
When will I know?
Brian finished?
Good boy, Brian.
Thank you for saying that again.
Oh yes, they've already been emailed.
I'm waiting on the responses from it.
I'm going to get a bit closer to you if that's okay.
Please don't freak out, okay?
I know I'm a real woman but it's okay.
I'm also like you.
So don't overthink your interactions together.
I'm born like you, okay?
I'm born like you.
Thank you, mommy, for blessing my eyes and ears.
How many submissions?
It was like 76 or something like that.
It was a lot.
Okay, so this is the only way I can see it being done.
So I've picked out.
These are all the cards that are one to ten, okay?
So we literally go like...
This is the first page.
Did I even have number one?
Number two.
So literally number one, right?
Fuck.
This is harder than I thought.
And these cards are in the way.
I can't believe it.
I never thought...
Wait, no, no, no.
Hello?
Are you there?
Okay, there we go.
It's double-sided.
I thought that.
Then it goes one.
And then we'll just take it from there.
This is the banger at the end of how full or empty it is.
Hmm.
That was funny.
I love your content.
I'm glad you can catch me live.
I'm so sorry.
This is like the worst stream to catch me live.
I'm just rambling.
I can't fit it in me.
Oh my God.
What?
That's so cool.
There's like a secret thing here.
Oh my God.
Hold on a minute.
I'm starting to understand why Pokemon cards collect.
A bit addictive.
Hold on a minute.
Oh no, that's satisfying.
Oh.
Oh, that's satisfying.
I'm sorry.
Hold on a minute.
Hold on.
Hold the phone.
What do I do with duplicates?
Well, I'll put them in a separate pile.
I'll put duplicates in a separate pile,
and I'll send it to Ariflin for the doughnuts on.
How about that?
You can have all my duplicates.
Nine.
So it's like one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Like, that's how we do it, right?
Oh my God.
The dopamine all along was putting it in the binders.
It wasn't pulling the card.
It was, oh my God.
Tell me.
Oh, sorry.
That is so fucking satisfying.
I'm getting dopamine hits, like fucking turning the damn thing.
Now, as I said, there's a very high chance
of you seeing my face this stream.
Look.
It is what it is.
Put it back in.
It's still good.
No problem.
You just eat what you want to.
Right.
So then we're on the teens.
We've got 14 to 18.
We've got 11.
That's a good one.
Right.
We've got 11.
So nine, 10, 11.
Huh?
Oh my God.
That's so satisfying.
What the fuck?
I'm making a game right now that is just putting stuff in the binder.
And I put you in the two mills.
I am trying so hard to get you a good shot.
Oh, hold on.
If I can, like, put you in the two mills.
And then we get Nemo, which is evolutionist camera.
Because he can't erupt.
So there's lava on the back.
Oh, my God.
The binding of us at once.
Well, Pikachu is a wispy.
So put it in the wispy pile.
Sorry.
This is so hard.
Right.
You know what?
Everyone calm down.
Let's move the fucking cars back in two by two.
I need a better camera angle, people.
Come on.
Think of the shot.
Think of the money shot.
Will you?
Jeez.
Any.
Keogreful.
Keogreful?
Okay, there.
Is that looking right up at my face?
I think it is a little bit.
That's it.
It is what it is.
Is that me?
In this one?
No.
What do you think?
I have no idea.
Right.
Okay.
I think I'm going to have to, like, swivele around.
Oh, no.
That's going to make it even worse.
The odds have increased of my face being shown.
Fuck.
Oh, well.
Yeah, well, wrap it up.
Right.
Okay.
Numeral is 12.
So, you got...
Oh, this is really hard to do.
I'm so sorry.
This is very unoptimized.
If numeral is 12, we have 14.
So, I guess we'll do 13.
12.
13.
14.
Wait.
Yes.
No.
Wait.
Hold on.
This is what I'm seeing.
This is what I'm struggling with.
I can't do numbers.
Well...
Yeah, and then next page, it would be 13.
Here.
And then 14 here.
Okay.
Sorry.
It's very slippery.
It's rather slippery.
I can't squeeze it.
How can I do it?
I mean, I want to be thebanger in the LA.
Wait.
Can I put you in between lines?
Is that easy?
I don't know if that's easier or more difficult.
Oh.
Well, if I squeeze it, it's actually a lot easier to do and go all the way through.
squeeze it it's actually a lot it's gonna hold okay so that is 14 and then
that's a repeat that's fine and then we've got 14 we don't have 15 but we have
16 17 14 15 16 and then we literally you get in the
second crushing fruit a bit early this is so hard
find out shortly that was 17 and these are duplicates and there's a 17 18 to
Pikachu so we're already on electric tape like what yeah like look how many
fucking gaps we have oh that's rough that is rough for a banger
need more gambas to sell the beans or I think that's how they're trying to get
you right this says so that's 18 right Pikachu is 18 and then we've got 21 18
19 20 21 have 22 whoa wait a minute my dumb not to have like a funny thing on
him like that hypnotist stuff well it has nothing on the car it's not to a
secret thingy put 52, 23, 24, 25,
Yeah, like all the sides. Yeah! Oh my god, what do you think? What do you guys think?
Okay, five, six, six, six, seven. That's fine. Oh, this is point two. Point one.
You get this. It's not shiny. It just looks slightly different.
Even with my naked eyes, it's in point 22, 22.
I'll show a big up close at the end as well, so please don't worry.
You're a Reefy in the city town. And in this 1819, 20, gorgeous stunning.
We're getting a bit more filled out. I love it.
Oh my gosh, this is speaking to me.
Right, that's pointy one. So we've got a Reefy. Oh! Yeah, look!
That one's different from that one, but this one's better.
So it's got the actual beef over it. That's going in the duplicate pile, and this one's from here.
So you think you could ever professionally compete one day with a dick?
I mean, I could compete whether or not I'd fucking win in the different questions,
but that's no harm in having a room tie dealer. Thank you for the three months extended membership.
No, there's absolutely no way. I could professionally fucking have a dick. Are you joking me?
I pick dicks. I pick my Pokemon based on do they look kawaii desune or not.
I'm not even going to hide the fact that I do. That's how I pick my dicks.
Are they cute? And you come. That's how I do it, okay?
Yeah, and she definitely is complete.
That's right. I picked them at their kawaii name. Right. What are you?
But I really cannot see that fucking number. Don't be afraid to make it bigger next time.
Twenty-eight. Twenty-nine. Thirty.
Do I have thirty?
I have thirty-one. Wait, let's get you in there.
Thirty-one. Gorgeous, stunning.
Oh, do you have thirty? Lovely. We love to see it. We love to...
We love to get in there. Thank you.
That was thirty. Thirty-one, thirty-two. We got thirty... thirty-one, thirty-two, thirty-two.
Wait. Thirty, thirty-one, thirty-two, thirty-two.
Sorry, I don't... I'm not very... You know, you know how it is, right?
You know, spondin'. I kind of spawned in as a girl.
I might not have the best kind of attribute, but as long as I try my best, right?
That's what counts, even if I am dumber than a bunch of rocks.
I'm just here for a good thing.
Thirty-three, and then that's thirty-five, which is correct.
And then I've got thirty-eight, thirty-five, thirty-six, thirty-seven, thirty-eight.
You've got a little pinch, just like you pinch the ball for.
And just do that with a little pinch, so there's nothing else that guys do.
And I was absolutely sponded when I saw a meme about it.
Alright, that was thirty-nine, so we're hitting them with a forty right off the bat.
No pun intended, you know.
And then forty-one, ooh, got a little clean slate going here.
Wait, what?
Apparently guys have to pinch and roll their sack in order to itch it, and I saw it in a meme.
And I was dumbfounded.
I forgive me.
I was not familiar with your game, gentlemen.
I was not familiar with your game.
Right, forty-one, forty-two, forty-three, forty-four, forty-five, forty-six.
Big gap.
I understand the gamble and the drive.
Oh, that's a good, good gap, and doesn't have to text on it that long.
Accurate.
Would you let me do it with my nails?
Come on, let me, let me pinch and roll for you.
Come on, let me do it with these nails.
Yes?
No, you scared of the nails?
Scared they're gonna hurt?
Someone sent me a marshmallow, they were like,
I'm starting, I don't mean to be asked such a personal question.
But I had to do it with those nails, and I'm like, well, see, I have the same post.
This is the peril, okay?
And this is the nails.
They have, they have not, the nails don't cut the peril.
It's not necessary.
Just, just so you shouldn't have, you know.
Oh, whoa.
Wait, no, I've not finished that deck yet.
We've got two duplicates, so that's okay.
And we've got Fampy and Dumfam, so that's 46, 47, 48, me, and 49.
And we're on the 50s.
And we're like, why is it so sad that I'm still not a vendor?
Like, I'm so happy right now.
Educational marshmallow?
Honestly, I don't mind educating.
I'd rather you ask me than never know at all, and like,
or be embarrassed to even try and learn.
Like, it's nice that you're even, like, curious enough to ask.
And it's like, well, listen to how it works.
Don't worry about it.
If you didn't know, because how are you supposed to know?
How are you supposed to know?
No, seriously, how are you supposed to know?
If you don't know better, how are you supposed to know?
That's a duplicate.
Haunter, these, actually, there's no difference between these.
So, I've got 57 and 56, and we've just done 52.
So, 53, 54, 55, 56, 57.
I'm afraid we didn't get ghastly, so we did not complete the game for everything,
which is a little unfortunate that we didn't really lose.
Thank you for watching over.
Some of us have much to learn.
Oh, is that a cherry, I say?
Are we up to date on marshmallows?
No, I've not looked at marshmallows.
You're gonna shit yourself, why?
I'm sure you're not.
57, 58, 59, 60.
Okay.
And then, as long as there's no scraggie, that's sort of, you know,
that's 60, sorry.
Sorry for some of my face there, no, I don't care that much.
Unfortunately, I do have a face.
60, 61, 62.
Hold on.
And then your duplicate, and then it was 61.
You're 62.
You're 61.
And you go, don't fight it, you're getting put away by me.
Okay, this one's the better version.
This is 64.
62, 63, 64.
It's very satisfying when you mean the bottom ones again.
Not seeing anything like this on, I guess.
Day one of the marshmallows.
It's trying to put, oof, steady on.
I think I've killed them enough for one, two.
40, 68.
What are you?
64, 65, 66, 57, 68.
Gorgeous.
Stunning.
68.
I must remember.
This is 69.
80.
60, 70.
71.
And we're just going to double check that math pencil,
because I'm not ready to do that.
60, 69, 70, 71.
And that's a duplicate.
Please stop playing.
Oh, please stop playing.
This is why you were getting thigh locked earlier.
That was 71.
So we've got 76, 79.
Okay, hold on, let's do the math.
Are you ready?
71, 72, 73, 74, 75.
And then it goes 76 here.
God, that gap is very difficult.
And then it goes 77.
Oh, Jesus, we are getting there.
We are getting there.
Who said pick this one?
And then 78, 79, like that.
And then if we have...
Oh, I've mixed this.
I've mixed this last pattern.
Oh, well, we're not as...
Should have been me, not the binder.
Thank you for having us.
Please don't worry, today's a much shorter stream.
Literally, once I put this away, we're going to take a look,
and then I was so much in my loop.
And I believe she'd be streaming.
And you can read her out there into her for once,
because I always end up missing her.
I feel really bad.
80, 81, 82, 83.
Crying at that backpack.
There's no unique...
On that.
I'm just checking.
Oh, there's a unique one, this Iowa.
And the backpack, right, outcome.
No, I'm not having an outcome.
See that?
The backpack at least has the unique little markings on it.
Iona, for you too.
Who said get nails?
Fuck sake, I can't get nails.
Out and...
I think I put more clothes on my dad.
There's nothing else in here.
I think there was loads of knockoffs, like,
fastened day.
79, 80, 81.
So...
A little bit more filled out than originally.
I don't want to do that.
That's what she said.
Who are you?
83.
What?
Oh, that's a duplicate, Iona.
84.
I was like, that's not possible.
How can there be two of the same?
84, 85, 86.
Okay, and then the last card.
90.
What was that?
86.
87, 88, 89, 90.
I'm not off my board.
That's how empty your fucking desk is.
I'm not sure how it feels about that.
Is this how we get you in?
Is this how they suck you in?
It's not very filled out at all.
Dear.
We've got greens, a lot of grass pipes.
And then, yeah, gaps all over.
Oh dear, this is how they suck you in.
I've not put these guys in.
That put them in the binders?
Are they going to fit?
Like, that put these guys in the binder?
How do you do it?
Buy more colourful cardboards.
I don't know.
Look out of Rudigan's number.
What?
Oh my god, can you see that?
224, hidden out of a 91 deck.
Are you serious?
This is 224 in a hidden deck?
What?
This deck is 239 cards.
And I've got this many fucking duplicates.
Excuse me, there's 239 cards.
Excuse me, there's 229 cards in the deck.
And I get how many duplicates?
All duplicates, by the way.
All duplicates.
No way.
That's insane.
See, being told that doesn't make me want to go gambling.
That makes me want to quit, because like...
If that was my booster packs, and these are all duplicates,
how you need me, you know?
Literally, that's how they need to buy more?
No!
I'm sorry, but they've lost me.
They've completely lost me after that.
Are you serious?
Like, that's more than probably what was put in the fucking poker deck,
not to be my poker deck.
Like, your poker deck is bigger than mine.
I don't know what to say.
I'm feeling emasculated right now.
Clearly bigger than mine.
Oh, there we go.
I found the energies, as if that wasn't enough.
Here's a bunch of energies that no one asked for.
Just print the...
Fucking just print the cards.
Put them in the bag, bro.
Put the fries in the bag.
Just put the cards that I want.
Oh my gosh.
Very hard.
And so that's why some Pokemon cards go for like a hundred bucks,
because it's such a very cool tool.
Thanks for the compliment.
Oh my god, it's called a V-Tuber.
Sadly, I am real.
I'm breaking all the V-Tuber rules.
Before you get excited and click subscribe,
I do break a lot of V-Tuber rules, okay?
I'm not supposed to acknowledge that.
I'm piloting a mess.
Yeah, look at that.
Empty.
I don't like that.
That's wrong.
I mean, don't get me wrong.
I had fun putting these cards away.
I was getting a bony.
Like, I was getting erect.
Putting that away, but...
We got...
I can't even...
Yeah, look at that one.
Holy shit.
One.
Out of eight on that page.
Oh no, two.
Sorry.
Two out of eight.
V-Tuber rules.
There's rules.
I mean, there's unwritten V-Tuber rules.
Like, one of them is like,
don't acknowledge your pilot and a metha.
I used to get told off for that so much.
Don't acknowledge your...
using your emotes or whatever you're looking for.
Then...
I'll send you a chat.
Hello.
This is our polka debt.
I'm not really beating anyone with this, to be honest.
Can these fit inside the...
If these can fit, maybe...
can these fit whilst still in the packet?
You might look a bit better if I can do those.
I don't know if they can fit with staying in the packet.
Oh, please.
It's invisible.
Okay, it's invisible.
Oh, it can.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Don't write me out yet.
Don't write me off just yet.
I've got 24 here.
Wait.
18.
Executor?
Oh, there.
Hardly.
I'm not sure.
I almost showed my face on screen.
Right.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hold on.
Let me put my specials in.
I didn't realise they could fit.
You know, it's a tight squeeze.
How was that specific?
Oh, it's struggling on the bottom one.
Is that in?
No, I'm just going to get schizophrenic now.
Oh, it's not in.
Hello, I'm thinking of do it again.
I'm so sorry.
Ooo, slide them in gently.
It is tight.
I'm not even kidding.
That is tight.
I'm gently...
I don't want to bend the card.
I'm really tight.
I don't want to bend the card or anything. I am gently.
Well, I've done it now, haven't I?
Okay.
Ooh.
That was tight.
147 special.
229 is Nemona.
Tentacruel, 213.
224.
69.
Nice. You have 69.
Just look for Neubat.
Where are you, Neubat?
69.
You look cute, Stanky Bean.
69. There you are. So this one will go up to y'all.
I'll give you a big...
Sound right, I've got 16.
Of course I would. Mummy, you're losing it.
It's just Corpheon.
Fucking...
Look how empty it is. I'm feeling a muscular lookie.
I'm trying to be like, all cute and stuff.
I love it. They're pretty rough.
Is anyone who have a Phil Pokemon collection here?
It's an expensive hobby, I feel.
This is 97.
90, 91, 92, 93, 94, 95, 96, 97.
You're cool. I'm putting in orders if I'm going to finish this deck.
Stanky Bean, 23, I do not have that kind of money.
Nor would I want to spend it.
Like, I'd rather have like...
I wish...
There must be Pokemon Gambo, but with less filler, right?
Surely there's someone who's like, well, cut to the chase.
Yeah, it's a bit rare, but it's not that rare, you know?
Like, I want to cut to the chase.
A bit different, you know?
Why, something on your name, Jason?
Is that what the bill says?
That's strange.
What would stop you from doing what you want to do?
90, 90, 89, 88.
Stop it.
Look gently.
Tease teaser.
Mm-hmm.
This way, I might let you guys do it.
Right, gently.
Come on.
No, I haven't forgotten that I need to take bulls.
Before anyone's like, have you forgotten?
No, I have not forgotten.
40.
Okay, back here.
40, that's 50.
Is this 40 on the shoulder?
It is.
Oh, I have a spacey and a duplicate.
Right, I'll take out this one, and I'll give it to Ari Fling.
Ari Fling, huh, Ari Fling, huh.
Chicken fried chicken, Ari Fling, huh.
Shawnee needs to take her team, I don't think.
I'm going to extend my way, can you get up?
Sorry, this blanket has too much fluff that comes off of it.
And then the blanket.
This is 70.
Still bizarre.
I've not had my book door.
I was there.
I even bought the webcam a bit too far.
Oh, I forgot my fucking mattress here.
Oops.
Ta-da.
That's how I say hi to you.
Hello.
Hi, hi, hi.
Shawnee, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Hi, Shawnee.
So, I had to pick it up, or else it couldn't see my face.
But now you can see my face.
I didn't realize I forgot.
Okay, 69, 70.
Hmm.
Is that a leg?
I know.
I'm not in a wheelchair, popular to...
Contrary to popular AI artwork.
Oh, right.
And then are these numbers like the outrageous ones?
No, this is 87.
That's not outrageous.
88, 87.
And then now it's the ridiculous numbers?
147, 2, 2, 9, 2, 1, 3.
Do I even have that many slots?
Right.
You're gonna have to walk through the math, okay?
We're my boy up.
97.
Right.
Everyone.
Shhh.
I need shushes from across.
And this is gonna be terrible.
97, 98, 99, 100.
101, 102, 103, 104, 105, 109, 110, 111, 112, 113, 114, 115, 116.
117, 118, 119, 120, 121, 122, 123, 124, 125, 126, 127, 128, 129, 131, 132, 133, 134, 135,
The following is a fact from UK-classified government documents.
Their accent isn't natural.
It's given a replenished by various brands of tea they drink daily.
If you drink tea daily, you'll develop one of the four accents.
Spread the word before they.
514, 6147, yay!
You missed one?
Did I actually?
Wait, did I miss?
Did I miss?
No, they're fucking with you?
Okay.
And that brain surgeon alloy you fucking with?
Stop fucking with me.
Right.
What did Brian say?
Hold on a minute.
Oh, excuse me for sawing my phone.
Brian's Edward Snowden.
The following is a fact from the UK-classified government documents.
The accent isn't natural.
It's given a replenished by various brands of tea they drink daily.
If you drink tea daily, you'll develop one of the four accents.
Spread the word before they.
Huh!
Yeah, that's right, British Edward Snowden.
Get done for.
You're either Northern Irish, you're Irish Scottish,
you're either Welsh, or you're either English.
England, school's not that good else.
Okay.
Thank you very much for the tip as well.
How could you forget?
Okay, 147.
Right, but it's not over yet.
Okay, we have two.
We have two 13 first.
Okay.
Are you ready?
I hope you like counting.
And it's not going down.
Sure you.
Right, 147, 148, 149, 150.
150, 152, 153, 154, 156, 178, 9, 6.
Hold on.
6, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 7, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 8.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 9.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 200, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 210, 210, 210, 211, 212, 213.
Yeah.
Can 13 even be in this position?
I don't know if what we're doing.
I think I had, I did it.
I think that's correct.
Two 13.
And then thank the fucking maker.
These are for 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
21, 22, 23, 24, right.
And then last but certainly fucking least because I've had enough of you.
24, 25, 26, 27, 28, and then 29.
And we're done with put the deck away, no duplicates.
Oh, that was so fucking hard.
I wish, Tina, why is it so hard putting away Pokemon cards?
Can't we just count the pages and multiply by four?
There, my deck is done.
Now we can look at my deck.
You want to come over in my house and look at my deck?
Oh, no, like my actual Pokemon deck.
I just borrowed it.
So I'll put it behind you.
Right, are you ready?
I'm going to present to you.
There are many polka decks in the world, but this one's mine.
There you go.
Well, it's empty.
Yeah, I'm buying mine.
I'll show you if I was saying deck as fucking set, straight, we don't be pussyfooting around
these bushes trying to invite you to our house to show you her deck, but you heard it wrong.
Oh, no, you accepted coming over to see foot on me.
And then it never happened.
You're like, so when you pulling it out and I was like, oh, I don't know.
You're in a Pokemon like that.
I thought you're more of a Yu-Gi-Oh fan to be honest.
I'm sorry.
Well, I'm familiar with your game.
Oh, I love my wee haunted.
I wish I could have got my wee ghastly as well to finish their line.
But you know what?
We got Ralts's line, so I'll kind of do that now.
She's pulling her cock out.
Wait, she's pulling her cock out.
And then we get to the special part and for no particular, look how far away the next card is.
It's so covered.
It's so covered, it's so far away, literally all over here for the next one.
And then for the next one, the other two are only visible because they are in special little pockets.
Who fucking made these?
That is ridiculous, honestly.
That's ridiculous.
It's donkulous.
They are special, and then two more.
One.
And then last, but certainly not least.
Apparently she's a rare pearl, so maybe I shouldn't be so mad.
And the ultimate key is ridiculous.
Right, where's her?
I want to see my Ralts's line though, because I always play Ralts in the Pokemon movie.
I always have a guard there, I always hold her super safe, so there it is.
There it is, I'm coming.
Look at that.
My Ralts's line is complete.
Imagine raising a Pokemon to be used for breathing stuff.
Very nice.
Very, very nice.
I get it.
He's the martial in my deck.
Did somebody mention Vaporeon?
No, mommy wants to be Guard of Air, bro, Guard of Air is such a sex symbol.
I don't care what anyone says, I'm such a sex symbol.
My large face.
Where my pack's good.
I kind of got rip-fozled a little bit.
So these were my duplicates.
Like, that's pretty fucking stacked.
For duplicates, that is, that's rough.
A discount guard of our design for Gen 2?
No, we don't, sadly.
Yeah, that's duplicate, that's rough.
Like, you can see how thick that is.
Like, I don't know if you have a Pokemon card for scale, just to see how thick this stuff is.
How about Gen 3 Guard of Air?
Do you want us to guess it?
Dick torture, yeah.
Is it torture when I play this game?
Yeah, sick chunky boy.
End point, best, isn't it?
Just don't call it Guard of Air, bro.
I should do my Pokemon deck through this one.
Yeah.
So that's my agendination, I think.
The other stuff, just in case someone didn't clean all the coins, I'll show them again.
And then I'll read Marshmallow.
Okay, so put one, put two, three, ignore the, ignore the discarding system, okay?
Just in case someone didn't grab them.
Ignore the discard system, don't, don't, what are you, what are you focusing on?
Oh, what are you doing?
Look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, identify yourself.
You're making a mess, oh no.
Should I not be making a mess right now?
So if you play the online game, you're more than welcome to clean all of those coins.
That is not a problem for you.
No problem at all.
Is there anything else?
A little player's guide, if you want to take a look at it, boom.
Oh, look at that.
I don't like when they do art like that.
I hate the fucking, how do you call it 3D?
I don't like that.
Pokemon are supposed to be, what?
It actually teaches you how to play.
I mean, it is a guide, right?
Colorful combos.
Cyborg for a mulling.
Espertha X is the angry, and it's Cyborg your opponent's Pokemon in the face.
What?
Build metal strategists, make it rain energy card when you Pokemon with
gold den or gold den goes, new lavish hospitality attack.
Pokemon like Metal X from Scarlet and Violet are amazing.
Obsidian Flames often have attacks that benefit.
Are these our specialty cards?
I've never had any.
Moonlight Hill has eyes.
Psychic decks get a new play through with Moonlight Hill, and there's no one better
to take advantage of the stadium cards than Garderbummer X, who debuted, oh my god,
Beach of Arreol?
Gen 3 Villar leaks?
Please tell me, you can read that says debuted, right?
Debuted in the Scarlet and Violet expansion, and now reappears in Scarlet and Violet halogen states.
Moonlight Hill, Moonlight Hill can help put basic psychic energy cards in your
discard file and heal damage incurred by psychic integrity.
Actually just confirmed?
We got both of those cards, I do.
Oh, just to rub it in your face?
Oh my god, just to rub it in your face?
They show you what you could have had.
I never even got Mimic, oh no, I did get Mimic C before, anyway.
I did get Mimic C, sorry, let me pop Mimic C in there.
Hold on, hold on, I forgot about Mimic C.
Mimic C was a special card, because look, we came in and we packed it.
Sorry, hold on, I forgot about Mimic C.
You know, you know the whole point of the box and the design?
Yeah, sorry, I forgot about that.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, I forgot about him.
And this is not holding him.
Deck appeared in the first place.
Doesn't wear glasses, has zero dents, perception.
I will go through what we could have had, okay?
I think it somehow had the perfect deck.
Oh, I love Mimic C, the safe card.
Prevent all damage done with Pokemon by the attacks from your opponents.
Who the fuck is Pokemon V?
I've never heard of Pokemon V.
Who's Mimic C?
Oh, he's right behind me.
It's perfectly behind me.
Right, 70, are you 70?
You're 75, right, go back to the book.
75, hold on, hold on, something's there.
What are you?
68, 69, okay.
70, two, three, four, five.
Here we go, little Mimic C's having a go.
There, now it's complete.
I'm 75, I'm Mimic C, 75.
Right, okay, let's rub it in.
Rub it in, let's rub it in, this is what we could have had.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh my God, they have shiny, these are the shiny variants as well.
Get to fuck, man.
There's no way you can organically buy a deck.
Like, via Gamba.
Via Gamba?
There's no way.
Hyper rear, shiny rear, shiny ultimate rear, above it.
This fucking post, yeah.
Uncommon, common standard of Ruth.
This is what, let's just pretend this is not Pokemon.
Oh, I can't imagine if we had that though.
Oh, and all the ghost tape.
Oh my God, what are you?
A whipper ghost tape?
Lord Shire?
Who's who?
Oh, the normal tapes, yeah, we had like one normal tape.
You look like Mimic C.
This is what we could have had, got any stars, can you say?
I'm sorry, I'm afraid to.
Oh wow, we could have had Abra on the hidden deck.
Fuck the hell.
These hidden decks are insane.
Holy shit, they have Padichur?
Lunatic Luxio?
Randomly just chilling out?
He's like, yeah.
Abra's in the deck as well?
What?
Who's who to forget about?
Like, who's actually feeling so shiny on the screen?
You're actually, you're expected to find out if he really, really likes Mudhip and
pray to him 50 Mudhips would all be true and rare.
Oh my God, that Mimic C.R. is so good on this one.
Holy shit, he's got a failed comma.
I love creepy little things, okay?
I love creepy little things, they're so fucking cute.
They're so cute.
Hawaii Disney.
Oh look, they're there.
I got the first one.
You got money to spend?
That's what I'm saying, who has this money to spend?
That's insane.
Oh no, that was the ultra rare?
There was the other variation of that trick?
Sorry, I don't see what you're talking about.
Do you think this is something different?
That looks like something different.
Muse in a bubble?
Yeah, well man.
Oh, that's the one we got.
Sorry, Nemona, this is the one we got.
Are we things creepy little things?
You are a wordable little thing, do you think?
God, there's a fucking God there especially.
But yeah, that goes for some fucking money, huh?
I don't know what these are, I don't think this is good.
God?
It looks like God.
Tengu, Wu, Qian.
Wait a minute, what?
Qian Yu, Qian Tao.
Wait, is Nihong good at?
I'm afraid I don't speak Chinese.
Are these being named after Chinese things?
Poraidon, Maradon.
It doesn't look like Pokemon, but it looks pretty open.
Oh hi, thanks for coming.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, right, let me read some marching novels
and then we'll be directing the series.
So let's go on.
Okay, what do you...
Quick, eat a card, please.
Do not eat a card.
You can have a video, please.
So, okay, hold on, adjust your volume
because I'm not at the microphone.
And yeah, well man, what are you doing?
I'm adjusting the table.
Griffy salts, hey, yeah.
Hell yeah, apparently, Griffy salts are real mean
and I didn't know that.
I just really like to take a look at it.
Okay, let's see about redirecting into Shibu.
And before Shibu's not screaming, I'm gonna cry.
Please tell me she's screaming.
I miss her all the time.
Right, let me say cheeky redirect.
Oh yeah.
And then we'll read...
Is my headset...
Oh, is that me making my...
Hold on, I think I can hear myself.
Is that me?
I think there's something...
Is it in my headset?
It's a member stream.
Are you joking?
I can't fucking hit Shibu ever.
What do you say?
No way I can't redirect into Sheepster's.
I'm like, oh, I finally do a stream where I wrap it up.
She's not screaming.
Oh god, she's in a collab later.
Oh well.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I'm just so nervous.
Let me rub my little feet together.
I'm so nervous about you.
I got to go.
Shibu actively avoiding me.
Confirmed, yeah.
Oh, her weight rooms aren't up either,
so I couldn't redirect.
The other feet.
Right, let me...
Is there anyone we can redirect into?
Well, I'll read Marshmallows.
So it's actually, the Marshmallows are the most important things
for wanting to get your facts right.
I'm getting my facts right.
I'm also getting them wrong.
Fuck you.
And I'm allowed to get them wrong, okay?
I guess we're not redirecting into any...
Well...
So, unless Emmy has her weight room up,
we can redirect into Emmy.
Yes, I'm going to send you into a stream
that's two hours away.
No, I don't care if he...
Does Emmy have her rooms up?
I'm going to cast this particular torsion on the girls.
I can't redirect into anyone.
Right, Marshmallow time.
Strongly wish you more luck on your pools.
The next card stream?
I'm not gambling.
I'm not doing that again.
Mummy, your hospital socks are adorable.
Do you like them?
National Zoom.
Better tours away for Emmy than...
Their weight rooms aren't up,
so I can't redirect.
Wait, Emmy's streaming today?
Is it?
And I'm looking at the calendar.
It says, strongy, 4am,
she be 6am members.
Yes, I'm leaking fucking veiler secrets.
Then it says, she be chained together with Emmy
So Pralto and Vivian Bloss for part two with Emmy.
She be an Emmy.
As long as you don't cast Andrometriosis,
I think Griffie thought, would it feel good?
I mean, I could put coconut oil on them if you want.
Hi, Mummy.
I tried applying for the script writer section,
but I never got the prompt.
No, you didn't get the prompt unless you were accepted
into the next stage.
That's why there is no prompt.
You're just to give your portfolio
and give a quick about you or your interests or what not.
No, there was no prompt given.
The prompt's given to those who made it on
to test their resolve.
Anime style.
I need to test your resolve.
Oil on Griffie thought?
Because what will it become?
Mercy has one off in seven hours.
Her uneye-curved cure, are you okay?
Yes, I will redirect you into a stream
that's seven hours away.
No, I will not apologise either.
Do you like the way my toes can bend?
I'm always like ready to run.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
No, wait, what?
Bend them around my tentacle.
Very straightforward.
Oh no.
Right.
Redirect.
Merchie.
And then I'll read the marshmallows
and we can chill for the rest.
If I may be a forward young leafling.
Maybe please get a pure unfiltered
brain rot earworm stream.
Oh, like where I just keep saying the stuff
that my brain says?
I'm not sure you're gonna want that.
I get very annoying very quickly.
Do you walk on your toes a lot?
I bend my feet like this part of my feet
at the toes.
I bend them a lot like all the time
my feet are bent.
They're either pressed up against something
or bent and sorry, I just realised
my hand was covering my face.
Sorry, let me recalibrate my tracking.
Real beautiful.
Hello.
Tell me much better.
Sony, can't annoy us.
I'll be the best stream.
Do you also walk upstairs on bent toes?
I used to walk upstairs on all fours
because it was so much faster.
I don't know if I've unlearned that yet.
I don't have stairs where I am.
But I think I still go upstairs on all fours.
Like if I was back at my family house.
I'm like 99% sure I still run upstairs on all fours.
Some decrepit dog.
Like I kid you not.
Like I'm chasing you out the stairs.
Like some fucking dog.
If I was chasing you out like nipping your ankles
on the way out.
I could see that.
I slowly talk about G-Mod in Pre-Chat
and I got hit by a wave of nostalgia.
Yeah, that was the first time I ever played G-Mod.
Glad to hear you've all enjoyed it with girls.
I'm a bit surprised to hear you can't stream the game
without lagging.
The lag was out of control with the ping and the delay.
Like I showed the girls how bad it was
and I was like standing in the corner for 20 seconds
waiting to move.
Like it just wasn't happening.
Shawnee chases you up the stairs
to put you to bed ASMR.
That would be terrifying.
Like oh I get scared of like the idea of being chased.
You know people are like oh I like pre-hunter type stuff.
I'm like I'm fucking absolutely fucking terrified.
Do not chase me.
I'll start screaming.
Okay you heard that scream yesterday
in the Subnautica stream.
Like I do not take chase and lately.
Is the members Overwatch VOD gone forever?
It can't come back on the channel
due to what happened in it.
I do have the full VOD.
I don't know what to do with it.
Well it was just too much.
Is the bottom line?
I mean I could maybe just put on blue sight later
once we actually use it.
The screaming is half the fun.
I hear that stream still in mind.
Did anyone stream Gmod?
No we were just playing together.
Shawnee is the monster that appears
when you turn the lights off.
Mummy I would interact more such as
in the stream snipes
what the reeflings are there for your
lovely voice if they heard mine
would all turn gay like the pinpals.
Oh is this reefling confident in their voice?
You need to come on the mic next time.
What's going on?
We've got a cocky reefling up in here.
We've got a non-R wordable reefling
confident in your what?
Get on the mic and the next stream snipe.
We want to hear it okay.
No pressure making those claims
around these parts partner okay.
Private reefling brother.
Shawnee calling your buff reefling.
So I'm sitting here watching stream
and pitching a tent.
What?
Oh the denial got me messed up.
I was going to say I was like to the feet.
I was like excuse me.
I mean if you like it that much
I can do a little dance for you.
Oh wait.
Can I do it?
How does Billie Jean is not my love?
She's just a girl who thinks I am my heart.
Oh shit.
But the kids are my shine.
What happened during the out stream
are you meaning to ask?
What happened?
There were consequences if you lost on
Overwatch with me okay.
That's the best way I got.
That's the most brunt brute force way
that I can say it.
Thank you Broly legend for the tip.
That is the most brute force way I can say it.
If you lost your game then you lost the ability to
pre-stream dance was true Scottish dance.
No you're not.
You can't be a vodling yet.
Not until the stream is over.
Vodlings are illegal until the stream is over okay.
The consequences aren't real without the vod though.
I mean I still have it on my desktop.
Shit.
You want me to open up the file?
You want to hear it?
Here's me.
Oh my god.
Meal and stream.
There you go.
I got the full vod.
So I don't know what claims you're coming out with.
Nice try though.
It was initially 480s.
It was a mis-input.
Hi strongy.
Most people that buy the cards want duplicates
because they play the game
and you need multiple for making decks.
How they are but it is makes this fucking hell
can't read your English.
How they make but is right you.
I have problems reading English.
You had problems typing English.
So together the combination isn't working
but it's okay there's other parts of our body
that'll work together just fine.
I assure you.
The strongest cards on the rarest
making people spend more money,
spend more money to try and get the dupes they need.
Okay.
Yeah.
I tried.
We both tried.
Okay.
We're having a stroke together
but not like that.
Hey moment.
Random question.
But was Space Marine 2 a trending on Warhammer?
Have you thought of doing Warhammer 40k in general?
So I did fermentide.
I've seen some gameplay of Space Marine 2.
I'll need to watch other people play it more
but I think we will do it together
if it's a stream snipe game.
If Space Marine I can get you in stream snipe.
I would like to play it with you for the first time.
I think it would be nice.
Um yeah.
This is now a feet stream.
You want me to talk with my feet?
So I think we can play Space Marine 2 together
but it has to be a stream snipe.
Will fermentide come back?
I think so but much later on.
Every syllable I hit my feet okay.
Hello.
Any good cards today?
Uh so yeah let me show you.
Hold on.
Wait.
Uh we got...
Hold on.
I'll see if I can show you the real ones real quick.
I know I'm further away from the mic.
Forgive me.
Uh kind of had a little shiny guy there.
We got guard devour shiny.
Are you ready?
The most important card.
The Bokuwara SEX.
SEX.
Unfortunately very empty deck but we got Noibat.
Uh Noivern.
Noibat lane.
Very happy with that so.
Um it's not the best.
We did get a very spanking rare like all the way back here.
Where is it?
We got a rare thing that's supposed to be a tentacrow
but they changed that.
I don't know what they did.
Bokuwara SEX.
And we got a rare pool on him.
A little wiggly worm boy.
And then our last pool was Neruso.
Oh no of course not.
Neruso's his youtuber that I watched.
Her name is Nemono.
Not Neruso.
Um.
Hello mom I just wanted to say that you're doing a good job.
You stop that.
I'm not giving brain worms.
Thank you.
I try.
Don't worry about it.
Some will just get brain worms and it's inevitable bubble.
But you're still doing a very good job.
Keeping them at bay.
Also interacting with you is not always good.
Imagine getting 48 days of no income.
No I didn't understand that.
It was a misinput.
A jail bird spot.
I just like Neruso.
I like her big fat titties.
Deep cups with X.
Oh wait she doesn't want us to say that anymore.
Oh.
I never said that.
Strony is short for stronethin.
Sadly I'm not smart enough to do something clever with cuttles.
So it doesn't beat Jimmy B soup.
I'm called stronethin.
Is that my legal name?
Fuck.
Stronethin?
Shit.
Can we take the socks off?
Reeflin!
No.
That comes late.
But I'll still talk through my feet though.
Hi strony.
I still have time on my no ink in your legs and thighs.
You're making it hard to get right.
Oh I just need stretch.
Oh look at the shape of that.
Look at the calf muscle shape.
Can you tell I ride a bike?
Can you tell I got some stamina?
What did Neruso say?
I could have sworn Neruso was like
I've had enough of yous being like I have big...
Can you tell I ride a bike yes or no?
Be honest.
Can you tell?
Do I ride a bike yes or no?
No.
Pray please it's my birthday?
I hope that bike isn't the only thing you ride.
Well I did say I'm re-sexual so...
And...
How long does it take for you to train your back door?
That's for another stream.
Okay.
Did we all enjoy the wholesome Pokemon time?
Sorry I just dropped the ball over here.
The idle foot cam is killing me with my boot bit.
Your foot interests.
They are so cute.
Please let me...
You like my feet?
Would you like them even more if they were oiled up?
Is there anyone here that's into CBT?
Be honest.
I too enjoy cognitive behavioral therapy.
It is great for helping your health and overall thoughts.
I wish I had something square...
I did!
Oh my god.
I was like, I wish I had something especially I could stand on.
There.
Can I slip on this?
Holy crap this is like so slippery.
There stop it you're being denied.
Have you seen that video where she's like doing this?
To the guys?
For no particular reason.
Oh, playing a bit fit.
Bit fit.
Oh yeah the Celtics on!
Celtics on!
Everyone shut up!
Celtics playing!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Don't know if it's possible but putting the missing OW2 stream on Bansley would be a good solution.
Probably.
Seeing what happened in the stream I think the reeflings who missed it would greatly appreciate it.
Yes, I can do that.
Just not yet because I'm not ready for it yet.
Oh, oh, Celtics on!
Celtics on!
She shoots!
Oh, she scores!
Let's go.
I lost.
Unfortunately I know where she's talking about!
I win!
Don't slip.
Oh, don't slip the slide.
Can't read it.
Oh, so this is the Pokemon stream.
Let's just put some cards in the viewpoint at least, you know.
There.
Now it's a real Pokemon stream.
Hi cuddles!
I'm much bigger and stronger than you but the thought of you dominant.
Oh, can I read these?
I don't think I can read these.
Ahem.
Do you want to float?
Love it.
Love it too, though.
What about the one with the guy in the floorboard?
Yeah, that was the one.
I was at Azura put it in the discord?
Like Azura randomly put it in the discord.
And she thought it was fake.
And it was like, no Azura.
This is real cognitive behavioral therapy.
And all of us were like, what is this?
And we all watched it and it was the guy like, oh!
And it was like, Azura, what do you mean you thought it was fake?
You can see it getting redder.
That was very much not fake, no.
Yeah, yeah.
It's thank you Nihongo or Nides for the tip.
But yes, the diamond diamond.
Some Pokemon card opened and this was off.
Are you enjoying the card?
Hopefully.
What's the gen donation?
Oh, I'm annoying you with Shibi tomorrow.
Yeah, me and Shibi are going to be a drill.
She's never played the portal to Azura into it.
I don't, I think she just didn't think it was real.
And she was like, oh.
I have seen it smashed between two boards.
Most horrific one I thought was a lady in heels
where she actually gives them a pure, oh fuck that man.
I think the worst thing I ever saw was like a flattening device.
But it was flattened to like, I'm not even like an eighth of an inch.
It was flattened.
Like, I wasn't saying.
A feet cam featuring some Pokemon cards.
Oh yeah, sorry.
I'm to talk via my feet.
Hello, Reefling.
Flattening device?
Yeah, please stop.
Well, I'm helping you if you're in the denial.
I'm actually throwing you a bone.
A CBT is also your special interest?
No!
Oh dear, poor Reefling.
Hi, Strony.
This has been the longest 48 hours of my life.
Well.
Flattening device?
More like Strony's cake.
Oh yeah, you wanna see that too?
Kidding!
You saw.
This is bad as the time as Narissa mentioned
giving a guy a paper cut and taking his...
What story did she tell us?
Your hands are funny looking.
I know they're claws.
I got fake nails on.
Let me see them.
Little fake nails.
Where the fuck is the webcam?
Easy, I can't find them.
Yeah, what an interesting design.
Middle finger and thumb only on the purple?
This is supposed to be purple.
It looked purple in the shop.
And then I walked outside and it's blue
and I'm like, I assure you,
we do not have a fucking Celtic and Rangers
bloody YouTuber model.
Look, me getting a bit political
around these parts, aren't we?
What, me?
Close beta testing.
Yes.
The Card Shop Simulator game
released full version,
which I really wanna play.
Sorry, I'm getting a lot of good feedback on my legs
when I'm stretching and things like this.
This feels really nice.
As I said, I always have my toes
pushed in against something.
If you can't handle strontia or stumpies,
you don't deserve her at her suppies.
Is your kitty around?
I don't think so.
Hold on, I can go ask.
I'll go ask Camely.
Camely, are you there, Camely?
Camely, where'd you go?
Are you coming?
I don't know if you can see her.
Come.
Come on.
I heard there's a...
Vigo doesn't like this one,
so I'm not gonna even ask him.
Get away.
Come explore the Pokmon.
Where are you going, Vigo?
She's...
She's no longer in this race.
She's a spirit.
I just need her to jump there.
I'm scared here.
Because normally I'm super quiet,
and then I get all nice and loud with you.
Who do you mean?
Camely's gonna chew on the corn.
Give him my things.
She didn't hate me.
She just...
Because I'm very quiet.
Like, I spoke on G mode with the girls this morning,
and Vigo was meowing his head off
as I was like, Vigo, Vigo, Vigo.
A peacock girl.
Interesting.
No, this is not peacock.
You can't guess from the colour scheme.
It's supposed to be purple and green.
You cannot guess what this type of girl
would be from the nails alone.
It is not possible,
but no, she's not peacock.
It is purple.
It's supposed to be purple,
but that's very blue on screen.
Hospital socks again?
When am I never out of them?
Hmm?
Have you ever seen me out of hospital socks?
I'm actually in the hospital right now,
and they just let me do what I please.
I give them no grief when I get to hang out with the refunds,
and I get to do what I want.
I get no grief,
so they let me have a little pee pee
in my little stream once.
Feet nails?
Nails.
Hmm.
There's a pee in.
Oh, there.
Mummy's in the hospital?
Yeah.
All right, I got to go get some dinner.
Rest well.
Thank you for hanging.
And I...
I'm actually going to redirect into emergency.
This is a much shorter stream today.
Down badling?
You can say.
Noodle arms.
Uh-huh.
Humongous cake.
Yes.
And some nice-looking athletic legs.
Uh-huh.
So looking good.
Oh, you want to taste?
You want to taste of this cuttlefish?
You like calamari?
Caramari?
Thank you, down badling, for the tip that you have.
Be proven from the psych ward, actually, though,
for real, for real, could you imagine?
I could pull that off.
Don't think I couldn't.
All you need to do is a bit of bribery.
Imagine, like, I'll be like,
look, let me get my nails done.
I'll give you a one-hour ASMR session through your heads.
Like, I'll give you the, like, headpats for one hour.
Boom.
Right.
There.
I got the stuff.
I got my nails done.
Okay, next thing I need.
I need materials and supplies and PC and monitor,
and I need a room.
So I'm actually in the staff room right now, okay?
I'm in the staff room of the asylum.
And they're just letting me be it
because I'm not giving them any tip when I'm like this.
Oh, God, Gira.
Gira's back, back, back.
Yeah, this is back, back, back.
Yes, this is back, yes, this is back, yes, this is back.
Do, do, do.
Don't ask why she's in that pose.
Don't ask.
Thank you for the tip.
Bam.
I think I'm in black today.
Yep.
Black, if you see that.
Why is she in that pose?
No, I don't know.
Don't ask me.
I don't know.
Hold on.
I'm just grabbing that.
I need my bobbers.
Right.
I'm ready to wrap up.
Is there anything I need to tell you?
Are you squiddin' me right now?
The face connect girls livin' a psych ward?
Oh.
I just forbidden lore.
Oregon, thank you for the tip.
Is this face connect lore that I don't know about?
You guys need to teach me about other retours.
It's weird you're in black.
I have absolutely terrible news.
I have absolutely horrific news about what I look like day to day.
I am a pale, pasty, pasty goth, okay?
That puts no effort into her appearance.
So.
You can hear like, huh?
I understand why people get parasocial over shimmers
after watching news, Ronnie.
Okay, I relearned what parasocial meant.
I thought parasocial meant you're coming to my house
and it was like dangerous.
But it's not dangerous.
And as long as it's happy, then it's good.
Like it's fine.
So thank you, Ethan.
For the nice comment.
That is how it means, yes.
You're too powerful.
And she's ever not wearing black.
I do have black rippy socks.
Terrible news.
Ronnie's in fact, demure and mindful.
That's straight up a thought.
That is technically parasocial in a way.
I thought if it was unhealthy, then it's parasocial and bad.
But if it's like, fuck, I'm actually happy
and I'm enjoying watching like shit.
I thought that was good.
Like, fuck me.
Fuck me.
Like let's jump into a match of fucking left for dead too.
We're going to finish the campaign together.
Am I going mental?
I think I might misunderstand.
Cause like, which is more grippy?
Ronnie socks or her actual bear grippers?
Oh no, I can go rip.
I have toes that fucking grip.
I assure you, I just can't do it with salt on, okay?
Trust me, bro.
I'll do it in another stream, okay?
Can get bad, but mainly just get social very vicariously.
Oh, that's a big word.
That's a big word for Elmo.
It depends how far gone mentally the person is.
I thought it was just like, you're nice to each other and shit.
Like you say, I love you, mummy.
And I say, I love you, reflin.
And it's like, Ken what?
If you don't fucking hear it, if, you know,
if you don't have got someone in your life that says,
Ken what?
I fucking love you.
Flaws and all.
Well, fucking excuse me for being the one to do it.
Like you do deserve to be told that you're loved
and you do deserve to be told that, like, yeah.
If we judged each other for like our worst fucking days,
would any of us fucking be here?
No, cause when you've had a bad day,
you've had a fucking dry day.
Ken, what I mean?
Or am I misunderstood?
I think I'm misunderstood.
I don't know.
Power socials character, great teenage girl,
loves actor, good power socials.
Ronnie and the reflins, good.
Reflins to Ronnie, good, stop or bad.
Right, okay.
Yeah.
Oh, how cute.
She's delusional.
Am I in the silence?
People can take it too seriously and go too far.
I love everything about you, Shen.
It's a spectrum.
What a good thing I'm an autist then.
I've mastered this part.
They are both good and bad.
Some people just take it too far and it's a bad thing.
I love her so much.
I love two people.
This right here.
I agree with this one.
Yeah, I just like, am I good mental?
I feel like if it was like,
I'm not playing games with you on stream.
I'm not saying I love you.
I'm not saying da, da, da, da.
I was like, why would you want to put your stonks
into a strummer like that anyway?
Isn't it not fucking nice to be told you're appreciated
and you're loved?
And yeah, you might be a lurker.
You might only talk.
You might only be able to catch me in the boards.
I am still appreciative of your time that you put into me
because you, I'll say it again.
I'll say it again.
You could literally be consuming any other content creator
right at this very second.
And yet you chose me.
The watermelon-haired hypnotic cuttlefish
that's done two hypnosis streams and called it a day.
Like, I don't know how to, I don't know how to tell you.
Oregon, thank you for the tip.
And Hydrus Simothadius.
Fucking good luck saying that right.
Thank you for becoming a member.
Please enjoy your moments.
I love your ASMR.
Well, you're going to be in for a treat tomorrow.
Oh, sure.
Yes.
And I wouldn't choose any other.
Thank you, my man.
Why are you called that?
You've got an interesting gamertag.
And birth an amazing gen.
Sounds really appealing to me.
Literally, like, do you want to make sure you're happy?
If you're streaming and you're happy
and you know what, clap your hands.
Hey, oh.
If you're happy and you know it, clap your hands.
You could see the thought forming in my mind.
You could see it forming in my mind
when the words came out and I did the fucking thing.
You could see it.
I'm going to sit on my chair.
I'm going to sit on my little game of chair.
Oh, no.
You can see the wheel.
Oh, my God.
How embarrassing.
You can see the wheel of my game of chair.
There.
Pokemon's from by the way.
We could see your hands in the shadow.
I love you, Strani, because you just seem cool.
Also, clap, clap.
Like, as you see, like, you're here to have a good time.
I'm here to have a good time.
We can play video together and stuff like that.
Parasocial can be that you really like the streamer
as a friend and want to watch and help her on one end,
but also can mean that you decide to find her
and try to visit her or hurt her.
Yeah, that's scary.
The streamer is only yours.
Depends on the mental from fan.
Yeah, like, that part's scary.
But the bit before where it's like,
fuck yeah, hold my hand through fucking Subnautica.
Like, oh, my God, I love that game.
Can we play?
I wish Subnautica was multiplayer.
I'd go fucking mental if it was multiplayer.
I'd be so brave.
I wouldn't be screaming at the reapers
or anything like that.
Thank you.
Bit of an educational link for the tit.
Yeah, I see that's right.
Personally, I'm happy to talk and flirt here.
And all the other reflins are nice too.
However, I don't think you have some deeper feelings for me,
especially since you don't actually know me.
Give me that dick.
Now, let's find out.
I'm trying so hard.
Had to become a member for the Great Vison.
Do not be expecting feet membership streams.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so sorry to disappoint you
if you signed up for feet membership streams.
I mean, I could do oiled up earcup and ASMR
with my feet, I guess.
Like, except only expect membership streams.
Like, I don't know if you saw it.
There was Goon Cave review.
Aw.
I'd love to take photos with Mama,
even if you're a TV on a stick.
A TV on a stick?
I can even wear my Mama's sweater
under score love, under score love.
Oh, that's okay.
Thank you, basically.
I've never been to a con either.
You want me to zoom about.
Can I run you over if I'm one of those robots?
Can I run into you?
I can give you a struggle, snuggle tackle
if I'm in one of those robots
and then I have to pay like $3,000 in damages
to the equipment.
Strongly takes your con chair at will.
It's been done before.
You can run into us, but you might fall afar.
To be honest, just the yapping stream
of feet in the background would be nice to.
I do love a good yapping, honestly.
Are you do larger scale playing with viewers?
What's in life or do you have an idea
that the other ones can come in
and play mountain blade banner?
We might do SCP.
I'm going to see if we can do SCP maybe for my birthday.
No, I'm just making memes.
Sorry, my bad.
No, you're fine.
Don't apologize.
See, yeah, brainworm.
Don't let the brainworms win.
I just don't know how to say your name properly.
Thank you for the tip.
Solve a Rubik's cube with your feet real.
I might try that.
Dangerous parasociality is pretty much never a creator's fault.
Let's not forget poor Bjrk had a literal insane stalker
in the 90s and she never read his Dono's or Erotic Malo's.
Oh!
Healthy fans know how to love some respects
with their friends' length.
Oregon, thank you for the tip.
Okay.
And she never read his Dono's or his Erotic Marsh Malo's.
Hi, Stronny.
I want to run my tongue up your legs and thigh until I've missed.
I memorized what your legs and thighs feel like.
Right.
Mount and Blade Bannerlord and have both fan bases fight each other
in the battlefield through their Oshii.
Honestly, is that that game where the guy was like Tally Ho and he died
and they have to like cock their guns?
Like they have to like shove the barrel up and down it
and then reload it?
Like that old game?
Bannerlord is pretty hard though.
Yeah.
You're on about him.
I think he can.
There's another game that's like, it's a multiplayer game
and there was like a really funny clip and he was like,
I'm going to make it and he dies instantly.
You might be thinking of hold fast.
It's a medieval war game.
Role blocks, rust, factorial, Minecraft?
I don't know.
I don't know what I want to do for my Donathon.
I really like doing the collab on the Donathon.
I thought it would be possible to maybe do crab game stream snipe.
I thought that would be fun.
Not all the girls have to stream it if they don't want to,
but I would like them to be there
and then you guys literally have the opportunity to stream snipe
like me and my gen mates.
Not just me, like all six of us are going to be in it.
Bannerlord is with the boobs.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't know.
Crab game is a bit meh,
but you guys would like genuinely make it much more interesting.
So I'm going to see if maybe crab game
will be the stream snipe one.
Factorial can have 65,000 people on a server at once.
How?
Who coded that?
That man needs some under the table support.
65,000 people on a server at once.
How is this possible?
What is crab game?
Crab game is a free to play multiplayer game
based on the squid games.
It was me.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it is possible through even on Australian ping.
Would I be the server host?
Your PC will not survive.
The SEC secret lab will be in person.
Splatoon, I'm afraid I've not bought the game.
Apparently it's actually bad for stream sniping.
Sorry, can't see feet.
Very big game not visually demanding in special circumstances.
Crab game would be hilarious.
Factory dev is addicted to optimization, clearly.
Is SAP free?
I think so.
SAP multiplayer?
Oh wait, would it be free if it's got servers they have to run?
Wait a minute, that makes no sense.
Right.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
I don't know, are you squiddin' me right now?
Parasocial is basically one-sided relationship.
Uh-huh.
It becomes dangerous when you become too emotionally dependent
and begin thinking the one you want is your special one only.
But then it becomes worse than parasocial.
Basically a negative three tiers above.
What does that mean?
Thank you anonymous for the tip.
So yeah, that's where I'm worried.
That's why I'm always like make sure you're having fun
because you know when you're not having fun anymore?
That's when I'm like you're not enjoying yourself.
Like you're just hurting yourself and I don't want you to hurt yourself.
Like I want it to be good fun.
I want it to just be like me mucking about opening up Pokmon cards.
I have no idea how to pull.
Yeah, that kind of thing.
Lamar, she puts her feet on cam like jingle and keys.
Jingle, jingle, jingle.
Gonna redirect into mercy in five hours.
Five hours.
Jingle, jingle, jingle.
But yeah, if you guys are okay, I'm gonna wrap it up.
Um, can we, uh, we can.
Five hour Yapathon, honestly.
Don't be silly and subject your willy to what you don't like.
The wise words are strony calls.
Absolutely true.
Redirect in five hours.
More like five hours a stream.
No, I need to go off because I'm gonna try and get the ASMR video off.
I'm gonna update my Patreon as well.
I don't know if I can do the caller for all and dog Zemma.
Not to be confused with X-Zema, the spin condition, or Yima, X-Zema.
This is a feet puppet show.
Okay, so this is an innocent little reefling here, and this is me hiding.
Jingle, jingle, jingle.
And the thing is, you can pretend to fight, but you're not gonna win, okay?
I'm too strong.
No reefling, accept it, accept it, reefling.
Let it happen, reefletch, let it happen.
And then boing, boing, boing, boing, boing, boing, boing, boing.
I'll show you the thunder side.
I fell down on my pants so long.
Who would ask to go?
A real reefling would never fight back.
The struggle.
Can you rotate strongly like a shark?
I can't show my bottom half.
It's not allowed.
Don't stop when I pass out.
Oh my god!
Prailing.
Aww.
Love you, mama.
Love you, mommy.
Love you too, reefling.
Thank you, Prailing, for the tip.
Yay.
I'm asked to come someday.
So can't stream as mommy works.
Do you want that for the membership writing stream?
I could do the membership writing streaming.
It's just a fucking video feed on my feet.
If you want.
I mean, shit, I'm not here to dictate.
Do what you want.
You're allowed to ask for the content you want to see around these parts.
I'm not going to be like, ah, don't backseat game me.
Ah, don't tell me I want to stream.
No, I'm fine with it.
I know, I'm being attacked.
Help.
I guess.
I love mommy because she gave me a place to belong.
Oh, that's so sweet.
Strongly Bottom is a WDM weapon of math.
They're bad, Sean.
My lawyer has advised me to end the drip game.
Now, unlike you, a shark, you immobilize strongy with
wrapping her in a soft blanket and giving her a head pass, and please.
Oh, you put me a bed.
Are you going to fuck me in?
You can't just tuck me in.
You have to do the other part too, or it doesn't count.
I'm not into feet.
Do what you're comfortable with.
You're like, oh, please wrap up the fucking feet, strongy.
Jesus, we get it.
You're wearing grippy socks, woman.
Please wrap it up.
I do love good wrap-ups.
I'm going to want you in.
Boko wa ya.
Right, I'll check Marshmallow one more time just to make sure.
Mommy, you're so cute.
Yeah, do you like how I get all excited when I get to do it
and really things, be anything?
Look at that toe spread.
Oh, my God.
Look at that pinky toe.
Yeah, damn.
Looks like I've webbed feet under those.
I promise you these toes separate.
Yeah, well, Mae, you're so cute today.
Thank you.
Hi, strongy.
I just wanted to say this real quick.
Thank you for your Twitter content.
It is freaking amazing.
I don't know why you sound like Elvis.
Thank you for all the fun streams and everything.
I love you.
I love you too.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know why you turned into Elvis there, but you did, okay?
You did.
Hi, strongy.
Hi, mithan.
I love you with every fiber of my being.
You have quickly became my kami-oshi.
Oh, no.
I feel so nervous when you call me kami-oshi.
I'm like, aren't you disappointed in me?
I was like, could you not pick a little bit better?
You're the most wonderful person I've ever known.
You make us all feel loved and appreciated.
You generally make my day better just with your yapping.
Yeah, you're like when I do feet puppetin.
Yeah.
I'm proud to be your riefling and call you my kami-oshi.
I will always love you and be here to support you.
Oh, thank you, riefling.
I love you too.
That's so sweet.
Nice screen to open up streams to.
Yeah, I wouldn't do it very.
I would close this.
The stream's over.
Let me put my feet on your mouth to silence you.
It's okay.
Just let it happen.
Oh, yeah.
There's one more hand cream stream at the end of this week.
And then I believe that's all my hand cam for quite a while.
Let me check my schedule.
I'll let you have my schedule open right now.
I'll put 25 Tenga celebration.
Soft clay form.
So that's hand cam.
And then it's dragon quest.
Conquer is bad for a day.
That's getting delayed for something else.
I've got a deep rock galactica stream snipe next week.
Like the next next week.
Star Wars Battlefront campaign's coming up.
ASMR stream's coming up.
Let me snuggle up to you, ASMR stream.
See how it goes.
Rock and stone.
That moment when the Bluetooth connects in the car.
You can see what the positive messages do to mama.
Close her toes go wild and erratic.
Yeah, we can see to the adorable mama.
Wait, my toes reacted to your messages?
Stop.
Did they actually?
Hold on.
I'm going to get that shit off the screen.
Did my toes react to your messages?
I'm having pepega.
Thank you, Pete Kling.
No permission for conquer.
No, no, just to delay it for something else.
Did my fucking toes react?
That's embarrassing.
I'm putting them under the cover now.
What?
Oh my God.
I was like, you got me feeling things and stuff.
That's a fact.
I don't know that.
I've got Left 4 Dead Streamsnip campaign on the 4th of October.
We'll go back to Left 4 Dead.
I think Conker's Bad Friday's getting delayed
and we'll try and wrap up Subnautica on that day.
I'm just looking.
I'm just straight up leaking the rest of my schedule.
I've got an ASMR maid roleplay.
Professor Layton.
I've got High on Life.
Never played that.
I've got Baking My Genmates.
It's coming up in October.
That's probably the next handcam.
But I'm calming it on the handcam for quite a while
because I've had quite a few back-to-back ones.
Not until I get new nails.
Okay?
I need new nails.
Her feet timed.
She covered them.
Am I ruining that?
I don't know.
Are my fucking toes reacting to your messages?
I'm like, oh my God.
That's embarrassing.
You can see me squirm.
Great for me.
I'm like, a fellow toe spreader?
What have you sent?
Are you sent a fucking video of your feet?
Hold on.
Have you just sent me a video of your feet in Marshmallow?
All right.
Ruflin, get your dogs off of my screen.
That's hilarious.
I'm like, why is your feet so veiny, though?
Are you a runner?
Why is your feet so pale at the knuckles,
but then you have like blood flow out,
like your ankle and your toe area?
You can't just ask someone that.
Why are you white?
That's funniest fuck.
Thank you, Ruflin.
That's hilarious.
Thank you for showing me your grippers.
It's a vampire vascular guy, I think so.
In her reaction, hmm.
Hi, mom.
I love you.
I can't wait to see what my technical comes.
Oh, okay.
Love you too, Ruflin.
Why are you white?
Hi, Johnny.
I just want to send this real quick.
What other stuff?
I'm playing control.
Apparently it's SCP adjacent.
Mines of Moria stream got delayed way at the end of October.
And then I'm going to do a test crowd control stream,
possibly, on Pokemon Emerald.
I don't know how that works, though.
I'm going to have to look into it.
I've got God of War coming up in November.
I've got BioShock Infinite in November.
I've got Mario 64 in November.
Johnny, do you really plan this far ahead?
Yes.
Yeah.
I literally have on the calendar
the May 4th Lego Star Wars Complete Saga.
Like, yes, I plan this far ahead.
And I change things out, okay?
The OG or the new...
Which God of War?
Wait, is it PS PlayStation only?
Yes, if you'll stop me.
Is it PS PlayStation only?
That might have to get changed.
The question should be if she's supposed to plan that far ahead?
Oh, I never read that.
No, don't message me that.
I've never read it in time.
You are a planner.
God of War is on PC.
Okay, that'll be the one I'm playing then.
The one that's on PC.
So we're there.
I hope you like Bioshock Infinite.
Yes.
What games are we talking about?
That's PlayStation exclusive.
I thought there was a God of War game that was PlayStation exclusive.
Look at these feet.
This is me cricketing.
You ever heard of a woman like,
I'm cricketing my feet.
This is it.
It's literally just a self-soothing behavior.
There's nothing more to it.
And it's a bit warm.
Teasing strong even redacted messages
because she can't read them in time.
No, it wakes me up.
I luckily, I caught that.
But oh yeah.
Oh, it really inverts my nipples
when I'm like reading halfway through your message
and then you're done.
I'm like, never got to finish it.
It wasn't me.
Damn, came at the best time.
The wrap up, yeah.
The original ones are P.O.A. station.
Yeah.
Momay.
Wait, what did I say?
Strony, I love you.
I love you too, this one.
It what?
Wait, what?
Am I getting, did I say something?
Do you think we could do
Trouble in Terror's Town Gmod Streams
now if you're the one hosting that?
Possibly.
I'll need to see if it shows IP or anything
like that, but possibly.
I think it's held by Gmod servers.
Oh, my nipples being inverted.
Yes, sorry.
Sorry.
I said, stop doing redacted.
I have no clue what users are saying.
No, I scoopy do.
Do you want tummy pics?
Am I allowed tummy pics?
Stop, I can't fucking read.
Strony, try not to overthink.
It's because I finished like my thingy
so quickly, like I don't,
I'm already onto the next topic
that I'm talking about
that I've no got a clue what's going on.
Yeah, I've got one more hand cam stream
on October, then I have nothing planned after that.
So if you're sick of seeing me
and not a Vtuber model,
it's because I did just a lot,
okay, but I'm wrapping it up.
I'm wrapping up.
Give mommy a head tap.
Stop with the redacted.
I'm missing them all.
One of the two new God of War games
in the first one is a PC.
I missed that, right?
What is redacted?
When you delete your message,
it says for me, message retracted.
Oh, those are two different words.
Retracted is take them back.
Redacted is hidden information and adult feeling.
Okay.
It's not as, stop!
I was just saying that!
Mommy is super sad.
Thank you.
Redacted is a joke from S.E.C.
about where the S.E.C. writer says,
Shania, I deleted my message
if I make a minor spelling error.
You struggle reading as it is.
I don't want to make it harder.
Okay, real unsure though.
We love to shume regardless with this hand.
I can't even read.
See how it even shows up in the hang?
It just says, it's just gone.
It's just no there.
Wait, before you,
I wanted to say that I think you're really funny
and you're my ocean.
Well, get right, I get right.
Are you doing okay?
Yeah, they're keeping me for a few more weeks
at the asylum, as you can see,
by the certified grippy socks.
But no, we had a really good Pokmon haul.
I enjoyed that.
I'm not buying more Pokmon though, fuck that.
Not one, I genuinely haven't had one.
Unless I missed it or it got blocked by the filters,
I generally haven't had one.
Generally haven't had one.
As I was saying, I think I've scared yous all.
Like, I think yous are scared of me
because I don't really get much
hmm and stuff and I'm like,
I think I'm just scared yous.
But then a refland sent me a marshmallow
and they were like,
like, I feel satisfied.
Like, I don't need to be a tumor anymore.
I'm just happy he's like watching you
and I'm like, oh, tea.
And I'm like, oh, okay.
Thank you, big belly-ing for the tip.
It's just weird to send that stuff randomly.
Oh, I mean,
do I need to, I'm down?
Do it real.
He's spitting real facts.
Oh, well someone said that.
They were like, I used to be a chronic
anchor but I'm not anymore.
And I was like, aren't I the problem though?
Because like, I do like non-stop,
shut the fuck up in about ink and this and teasing and that.
And I'm like, aren't I the problem?
But the refland says no.
And I'm like, okay.
But aren't I the problem though?
But no.
Mummy, did you know redactors yet?
What?
Don't worry, I'll turn just a minute.
Don't be shy, put some more.
I don't want to be hate, I just want to be happy.
Yeah, yeah, like basically I think
is what I boil down to.
Hmm, don't send unasked for stuff
if a thing does get full though.
I guess I'm such an exception to the rule.
I think actually I want to just do the brainworn stuff a bit more.
I was like, I'm going to be honest,
have you been fucked up by a VTuber before?
Because you're so terrified to like say these things to me
or do things around me.
I'm like, what nasty VTuber had a reaction to you
that was so visceral to make you so cautious?
Like, was someone nasty to you?
Do I need to go speak to the manager?
Like that's such a shame.
I feel really bad that whenever you interact,
instead of being like,
oh, strong is like having a hoot and a holler,
you're like, oh my god, I've messed up.
She's going to end up blocking me,
muting me or whatever that.
Like, I assure you I've not muted one motherfucking person.
I've muted two people on Marshmallow.
One was harassment,
and then the other one was really random racism
that wasn't even shown at me.
That was a bit bizarre.
I don't know what about, I can't decide for the message.
Not VTubers, but girls.
Most VTubers don't like weird comments.
Oh boy!
You are in for a treat over at your home.
It's not even just online.
It's what we've been taught in Relay.
I mean, I guess in Relay,
you wouldn't like go up to some random check
and it can be like, hmm, your feet.
But you know, here.
And the gloves are fucking off, okay?
My gloves are off.
Feet!
Hi, DEMPA.
Sorry, we've wrapped up the Pokemon,
but we did play Pokemon for real for real, okay?
Look, it's real.
I promise I opened up Pokemon.
It may not look like it, but yeah.
I inked DEMPA real once.
I think it's just good manners.
The world has been hard on the phyllis,
darling, you know.
Culture is told is not to be openly,
hmm.
I guess, yeah.
No, I do understand that.
I guess that would explain why
some overthinking comes into it,
because I do feel bad when,
like, we have a carry-on on streaming and,
you know, I'll go brainwrote for a bit
and then I'll check Marshmallow
and it's apologies.
And I'm like, what are you apologizing for?
We're having fun together.
We're playing games together.
We're chatting.
We're, I'm reading chat.
I'm reading you.
I know there's lurkers,
if you're lurking in the shadow, don't be.
Don't feel forced to talk,
but, like, I know you're there
and you're just bitching in.
There's a man, I'm bitching in.
Wait, people send apologies?
I kid you not.
People, like, are literally, like,
strongy, I'm sorry that I did this,
I did that.
And I'm like, oh my God,
like, you've actually been so fucked up
because of something before.
Hin Law.
Hi, lurker here.
Hi, lurker.
Lurker Ling.
We'll call you lurkers.
Um, mm-mm-mm.
But yeah, like, uh, hello, lurker.
Hi.
Oh, you're being brave, little lurkers.
Are you feeling the pressure?
Did your heart rate go up when you typed?
Lurker Love.
Yes, I know you're a little lurker.
You're allowed to lurk, it's fine.
Um, I'm not, like, feel the pressure,
like, you must talk or anything like that.
I feel a genuine level of acceptance,
more freedom in a sense.
Brain feels better when I sit in stream,
whether it's lurking or participating.
We are gentlemen first.
Oh my God, hold on, wait.
Wait, I have the sound bite.
Oh no, I don't, because it's not popping up.
A true gentleman.
Um, I almost had a heart attack.
Oh my God, stop!
Wait, am I elevating your stream?
I was a lurker before the stream, yeah.
No, you're allowed to be lurker.
For any lurker that's, like, I don't,
I'm too scared.
Don't worry, you don't have to,
you don't have to say anything like a true gentleman.
Um, I'm just straight up lurking.
And by it, let's just say my beacher bird.
Okay, that was really good.
You win comment of the stream.
Plop, plop, plop, plop.
That was actually really good.
I'm a gentleman and a scholar,
but I like Dom's one.
Oh, you like Dom me?
Okay, thankfully I didn't send one.
I find it very hard sometimes having brain worms in the path
and I felt like sending me apology.
Good thing I didn't.
No, it's not a bother.
No, don't get brain worms if I haven't brain worms
and apologize.
Don't get brain worms if you've apologized either.
Hold on, pause, pause.
Don't get brain worms either.
It's okay to apologize,
but what I'm trying to say is you don't like to apologize.
Wait, grug?
Grug like women.
Grug like men in prayer?
Grug as in red?
Grug?
Red, is that you?
Thank you, bab, for the tip, my little guru guru.
Oh no, the brain worms have brain worms.
No.
Is that red or am I just...
Brain worms squared?
I feel like if you read more suggestive and you rap positive,
it's all good, but I'm not saying anything wrong with either.
You're too kind, I love you.
I love you, sir, you're fun.
Oh, hi.
Oh, hi there.
Oh, should I start calling lurkers out?
No, that puts you on the spot.
That's not fun.
Sometimes it's tough to be a gentleman and a bit on the side.
Don't worry.
I lurked two weeks before I interacted with you for the first thing
because I want to have a good idea of what it's okay to say to you.
No, I feel like literally I have to be like,
all right, reflins, remember when we go into other people's streams,
they're not like me.
Grug as in a caveman.
Ah, okay, okay, I'm mistaken identity.
My apologies, guru, at the door via a doorbell.
Oh god, now I have to apologize even harder.
No.
You're not to apologize even harder.
Stop it.
Hey.
Mom, I like to send you an ink tax.
What the fuck?
That's so good.
The ink tax, the ink tax.
Mommy's tried hard, so you better pay the price.
Mommy's been a tease, so you better call for that.
So anyway, when it comes to talking to you during streams,
I get nervous when talking.
I find you so beautifully attractive and you get nervous.
No.
Are your feet cold?
They actually are.
I'm getting a bit chilly.
Are you okay?
Is that cool?
I don't chat often in streams or really post comments.
I felt like the eye of Saruman found me
when you replied to my comment.
Do you have a ring for me?
Do you still have the cherry associated with that ring?
I really love you all so much.
I'm a lurker, nine times out of 10, but when...
But I talk when I can.
I really love you all so much.
Aw, Riefling.
You guys are super funny and sweet and lovely.
Thanks for having me, Riefling.
Aw, that was so nice.
Thank you.
Hey, I wonder if she realized she's reacting with her feet again.
Meow.
No, you can't prove it, okay?
I am the danger.
What if you tell them that they apologize to get punished?
I feel like they'd want that.
That Riefling experience, the whole body turns up.
Bless all.
Does it make you...
I like when you tell me stories,
like it makes you smile when I read your message.
I'm like, ah, I can't handle it.
It's so fucking cute.
Like the thought of you cheesing behind your keyboard right now.
Stop being so cute.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna start passing out the R-word.
And like the thought of you cheesing behind your little keyboard
is so cute.
It's so fucking cute.
The chat reflects the true word.
Shawnee is so cute.
That's why you start quivering, dimple.
Cuteness aggression.
I mean, of course, we get happy if you read our message.
We are shy when you do that.
That happens to everyone.
Riefling.
You stop being so cute.
It happens to me through real.
The amount of dopamine I get when you read my chat message
or when I get a like from you on Twitter since we're flying.
Oh, I don't, I'm really bad at using Twitter.
Actually, I'll tell you what.
I've got a funny Twitter post.
I'm gonna post this in TM.
You better start our wordness then.
Oh, deals of deals.
Shit, you got me.
You caught me.
All right, line up.
Line up.
Who's first?
Twitter hate, honestly.
I'm just rubbish actually.
I told the giggle when I got a comment right out there.
I need squid mirrors though.
No need for them.
Brain dead VTuber fan.
You're not brain dead.
You have to be nice.
You need to name yourself positive things.
You should call yourself two brain cell VTuber fan.
There's your new.
And then you can celebrate each new brain cell yet.
Thank you for coming to member.
Please enjoy your moments.
Stream went from wholesome to hate to wholesome.
Yeah, that, yeah.
Not gonna lie.
That stuff kind of happens around here.
Witness me.
Me, me, me, I'm fine.
Brain raw VTuber fan.
Well, honestly, if you're a member for me, I'll take it.
Stop redacting your messages.
I sent some letters during dead hours.
I'm so embarrassed to hear you read it on stream.
You get embarrassed, but your marshmallows are anonymous.
I can't even tell.
Sorry for not having sent a marshmallow yet.
Please forgive me.
No, don't be sorry.
That's, don't, don't be sorry.
Our wordness is gonna start happening if we start.
Mmm.
You just typed message redacted.
That's not actually been redacted.
Welcome to strongy stream.
If it's your first time.
Hi.
Did I pop your cherry?
Maybe a little bit.
Little cherry popping today.
If you see me for the first time.
Oh, fuck.
My ankle's about to crack.
Sorry.
Ah, my ankle's about to crack.
Sorry, mommy.
I apologize for not giving a fuck.
Yes.
I saw that.
I read yes before you got it.
I'm sorry for that.
Reefling being sorry.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I'll tell you how I get used to stop saying sorry.
I'll tell you how I'll get used to stop saying sorry.
You already know.
I know how I'm gonna, I see one more sorry.
And if I see one more sorry in that chat.
It's getting done.
Please don't.
I'm sorry, mommy.
Don't do it.
Message.
Sorry.
Okay.
You're getting punished.
Naughty refling.
Yeah.
You feel that pressure?
Bad boy.
You know, bad boy.
See this?
We're totally punished.
Bad refling.
Don't do it.
It's too late.
I'll threaten again.
Look, I'm threatening again.
No more s's.
Message.
Sorry.
Reduct.
But what about gen two?
I think we're like what, a month?
No.
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna be pregnant in less than a month.
Oh my god.
It's the 17th today.
Oh no.
This can't be.
I'm gonna be pregnant in a fucking month with gen two.
Shit.
Better get your tentacles ready.
We're gonna need a big load for gen two.
Prepare yourself.
Yes.
Dying less fast.
No, I need to get pregnant with them.
I need to be pregnant with them.
I'm getting pregnant on my birthday.
I've got some work to do.
Is that what you're denialings are for?
Do you get a special model?
When I'm pregnant,
you want me to have a special toggle?
I think it would cost a lot.
Uh, I don't know.
Do you want me to fucking...
Oh, my big swollen belly with my big swollen milkers?
You want a pregnant version of Strawny?
Jesus.
Yes.
Is there anyone that's done a prego feature for model?
I just want you to see where Dune's cuddle.
I'm not gonna do three-deal.
You can't hear when I cuddle this microphone.
It's so annoying.
I can, like, rub it.
That's gonna scare the new people away.
Yeah, I think that's probably more of an incident joke.
Yeah, no, pregnant.
Kids, just place the prego barely P&D on top.
Yeah, that's a lot cheaper as well.
You know what?
You're right.
That's a lot cheaper.
Stretch marks, Strawny.
I already have them on my thighs.
I used to be a plank, and then when puberty hit,
my hips, like, doubled in size overnight.
It was bizarre.
It was truly bizarre.
So I have, like, stretch...
Like, did they call them tiger stripes or something there?
It's not stretch marks anymore.
But I have them on my thighs and my hips.
And no, my thighs.
Sorry, my hips.
Hips only.
Brea...
Proof?
Are you not seeing my...
Oh, I don't have a shirt on under there.
Okay, am I going crazy?
Have I never showed you guys my...
I don't know if you can tell.
Hang on.
I don't know if you can tell, because I'm like...
Oh, you can't.
Holy shit, you can't.
Wait, no.
Oh, you can't tell?
Oh, I look like a plank.
Oh, well, I'm not actually a plank.
It's just...
It's the bad camera angle, okay?
I was like, have them on!
You know, kind of go a little bit hip-pitch.
You know, if you've ever been on the alt-wear.
That's a lot of hip-pitch.
You're a plank from the front.
Yeah, there you go.
Plank.
I can't find my glasses.
Hips for birthing veal or generations, literally.
You edit it out of the picture.
My hips?
I smooth my skin.
I don't have nice skin.
Like, I have skin.
Smooth the skin in my face, but I don't...
Oh, the marks!
Yeah, I edit the marks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The skin.
I fix the skin.
Try to remove everything.
Birthing hips.
Stony's personality.
Breeding bros win.
She has normal skin.
The shock and horror.
I know.
It's terrible.
Mummy, when you read my messages or when you, like,
my art or, like, my tweet, I get embarrassed
and I get butterflies in blood.
I, like, run around my room and jump.
Stop!
That's so cute!
Oh, my God.
God, I want Stony to just grab me and drag me
while I hyperventilate and grab for the furniture
and walls while she takes me into a small dark room
and all that is heard is muffled moans and wallbangs?
Reeflyn, you have a very specific intro, don't you?
We're on to you.
You have a very specific intro.
Yeah, no.
Mmm.
Mummy, I love when you read my marrows.
I sent all of them.
Am I getting one reflinged here?
Mmm.
Hey, Stony.
Hi, Reeflyn.
Today, I went to Costco.
It may not seem like a huge deal,
but I normally get really anxious when going there
and it's busy.
Ah, I hate when it's busy as well.
There's always a lot of people and I get overwhelmed,
however, after I talked to you, even the little bit
that I did, I was able to keep it together
and not have to leave early this time.
I thought back to how nervous I was talking to you,
but how worth it it was to say I love you and it helped me.
And thank you so much.
Oh, Reeflyn!
What the fuck?
That's amazing.
I'm glad you got your little cost...
Oh, Costco!
Wait, Costco's a supermarket.
That's so good.
Love you too, little Reeflyn.
I'm so glad.
See, it was in you all along though.
You have to celebrate your victories.
And that wasn't me.
I wasn't in the shop way.
That was you.
You did that.
You were doing fantastic.
And that was you.
I cannot read that fast.
I saw that.
That was like a fucking essay and a half
in the corner of my eye.
I cannot read that fast.
We're a figment of strong ease of imagination.
You better not be.
Either I'm going to be pregnant next month or not.
Take responsibility.
All right.
If you're not rapping it, take responsibility.
Meeting me pre...
Six!
I was pregnant with five.
Now I'm pregnant with six.
I can't read that fast either when I'm talking.
I fantasise about not being each other aggressively
while we exercise.
One, two, three, four.
That's basically if we're working out.
That's how it's going to sound for me.
Remember buying stuff in Costco during the pandemic?
Have to pay child support through working on the farm.
Yeah, working.
Working.
I'm sure we'll be harvesting anything from you on the farm.
Everyone help for sins, mum and gen two.
Yes.
If we keep apologising, do we get grape time?
Oh no.
Nice zorks, yeah.
You're like the mental asylum.
That's the replete Alice Madness return.
This would be the first time I actually would.
So hesitation.
Can we have a shotgun wedding after a prequel?
Oh my god, do you want to do that?
A little wedding rules.
I need to figure out how to use both.
Both is how people have like outfits that their head is like a head is still on it.
I don't know how to put a wedding dress on me.
It's going to have to be wed and dress PNG.
I'm sorry.
We're going to have to consummate the marriage as well.
Just so you know.
Just so you know, we're going to have to consummate the marriage on that
after the ASMR wedding.
So.
Mom, I tend to lurk for weeks because feeling comfortable commenting and live chats.
Some communities can put you all for hostile but your community is so friendly,
so comfortable typing stuff.
Oh, I'm so glad.
We've still got stinkings.
She knows right?
She can teach you.
I don't want to be a bother.
Shotgun wedding, hopefully, since one is hell.
Yee-haw!
That would murder me in real life.
Worth it.
We should get married before gen three.
So when we consummate your prego with gen three?
I don't know.
Oh wait, no.
Because that's speedrunning.
No.
I need a not...
Bruh.
This...
The tank needs to be empty, okay?
Morning, Scottish mummies.
Good morning, this one.
Thank you for the stream today.
Did you enjoy it?
Even though it's just me going...
Oh, I was supposed to wrap up like 30 minutes ago.
I'm weak.
Hi, mummet.
I don't know how much to say except a miss.
Oh, I love you.
Many kisses.
Hey, mummet.
Your streams have been quite some freedom for me.
Freedom, you say?
For the Scottish VTuber?
It's a given around these parts.
Big Willy Wallace didn't die for nothing.
Freedom around for the Scottish VTuber.
I have quite the perverse mind, isn't it?
But I've been flamed by VTubers and communities before.
And I kind of ganged up with hate mail because of it.
Somewhere bad.
So your streams have been quite enjoyment for me and for Incan
and just having fun and positivity in my brain.
Thank you for being here.
I hope in the future I get a girlfriend who has your mindset and personality.
I assure you.
I ain't the only one...
I'm not the only one built like this.
You need autism, ADHD and an accent.
And there you go.
Boom.
And that's it.
That's all you need.
So a little bit of microplastics on the brain to cause the autism
and the ADHD and the rest is good to go.
Good to go.
Okay.
Wedding is part of the doughnathon right before the first blue site stream.
Oh, hold on a minute.
Wedding is part of the doughnathon and then consummation.
Hmm.
Now we're playing 4D chess.
I'm playing checkers.
You're playing chess right now cause hmm.
No, hold on.
Let that man speak.
The first blue site could be the honeymoon.
I think that would actually be very nice.
I'm not sure about you.
Mummy, when you read my marshmallow just hid better in my phone.
Are you cheesing?
I don't have a fetish but your feet and socks are cute.
Thank you.
I got them from the mental fund.
Mummy, can I ink today?
Are you being denied?
Are you trying to skip?
Hmm.
From a lurker.
I love you.
I love you too, little lurkerling.
You're so cute.
Do you smell what the rooflings are cooking?
Sounds really cute.
Hmm.
Hi, Strony.
Sometimes I pitch a tent when you do those fake tears in them.
What are you talking about?
I'm just stretching.
Ah.
Just stretching.
Yep.
Nice hooves.
Yeah, you like that.
No.
Your marshmallows go eh.
I'm at four minutes ago.
This is a double sentence.
I don't know if I got caught if you did then ignore.
Thank you for everything.
Even though I have Enrily friends,
I don't have much in common with them.
Oh my God, I felt that.
So I still feel a bit lonely not to mention that I'm 26.
And oh, Jesus.
I have yet to have a girlfriend.
Veiler has been a massive help for my mental state.
I didn't really...
Wait a minute, you have cherries, don't you?
I didn't really watch streamers before,
but the girls are giving me nothing but joy.
And it's not just the girls.
Sorry, I'm reading a lot of English here.
Being a part of the community of like-minded,
independent jewels have finally given me a sense of belonging,
especially during the Overwatch stream.
Dropping around with you, chat, and the other guys in the lobby
has made me the happiest I've been in quite a while.
So again, I can't thank you enough.
Honestly, I'm saddened a little bit.
I'll never be able to repay you.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You don't understand.
I will never be able to repay...
Wait, 26 is that what you said?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
No, I don't...
Aren't most reeflings 30 plus?
Oh, he is!
Oh, that's kind of hot.
You're over 30 and you're letting me control your ink.
Oh, that's hot.
You're letting me be in control.
Oh, my God.
You're letting little old me,
a little five foot three tiny,
wainy little Spironee control your ink.
Shocking.
I'm 40.
What does that mean?
You have bloody good taste.
Oh, my God.
That's so good.
She didn't know a big part is 30 plus.
I guess not.
32, 28, 20.
Plenty of cherries on you.
I could smell the cherries on you.
I just turned 25 though.
Okay.
Because you're idly gonna...
Because you're idly this when I tell you my age.
We need to do a reefling demographic.
Where are my other...
I'm 23.
Where am I 24?
I can smell you.
How old do you think the youngest person here is?
18.
No one else under is allowed to watch our advice system.
We do not accept.
36.
The little spike ball.
Goddamn.
The real chair, boyhunter.
Pull it.
What?
Like the average...
Hold on.
Wait, I can't do a pull.
Oh, my God.
I'm supposed to be working right now,
but I like talking to you too much.
Age range.
Okay, add option.
Let's do 18 to...
24.
25 to 30.
31 to 35.
And then 36 plus.
And then true will do some.
That's probably not how I was supposed to do it,
but this is anonymous.
Like, it's not a thing that you sell out.
Do you see it?
Wait, did I do it wrong?
Are there any other reasons that are also from someone?
36 plus dang.
Real OG-san.
True OG-san.
Get their category.
I mean, fucking look at me though.
Like, I'm not being weird or funny,
but like, I'm not being funny.
Gomenasori, if you don't like seeing,
you're letting me control your anger.
Look at me.
Do you understand how hot that is?
I mean, shit.
This is the size of a Pokemon card in my hand.
And you're letting me control you?
Come on, that's fucking hot.
I don't care what anyone says.
That is...
That's each word.
I don't care what anyone says.
I mean, look at me.
I write a bake.
Like, fuck, and you're letting me...
I'm a cyclist.
I'm the lowest of the lowest scum, okay?
You knew that?
Okay.
What can I say?
I like your stat.
I like your funny words, Scottish lady.
Your hands are like half as big as mine.
This is very plausible.
Apparently I have very tiny hands in comparison to you guys, so...
Oh my god, it says my name,
my blood type, and social security after voting.
I'm coming to your house now, got ya.
Okay.
Nah, you guys are...
Yeah, you guys are getting my ages.
She's a cyclist.
Waterboard her with McDonald's spray, real.
We just love you, Momela, you too, you son.
Keep going on.
Like, a bake cyclist?
I cycle all the time, shoulder to shoulder, with semis.
You've got a semi, you say?
Sorry, you're being very serious with that sentence.
I cycle on the pavements, which actually is illegal,
because I could hit a pedestrian,
but I don't want to go on the road,
because I don't want to get ran over by a car team.
Yeah, I'm a 36-year-old man who owns the house and has a job,
and I'm on the other side of the road.
Please control my ink, it's all for you.
Fuck!
That's crazy!
But in a good way.
No one did.
Mmm.
Hello, I'm the 26-year-old reflin.
Yes, I still have every single chair you want it.
Please!
Oh my god, I need to do a fucking meta roleplay right now.
You can't bike on the sidewalk on the pavement,
like, where people walk, isn't it not?
In Scotland, it's illegal,
but the police never told me off for it.
Like, the police used to see me a lot.
Oh my fucking god.
I used to see the same fucking egg to Polish men,
like, day in, day out,
and they'd always look at me,
and I'd always be like,
oh, you fuck, they're gonna say something,
because it's like, you're not supposed to be on the pavement,
or you'll get, like, because you can hurt someone.
Evos, thank you for becoming a member.
Please enjoy the emotes,
and thank you for the support.
Sorry, it's a bit fluff on my leg.
But I look very visually quite young in real life,
like, not on camera or whatever.
Visually, I look quite young,
and I think that's why the police never said nothing to me,
because they were always like,
oh, she's like a teenager,
she's like still at high school and that kind of thing.
To polis, the polis.
Polis men, policemen, polis.
A Shawnee gremlin.
They have home, two cars,
and live across the world.
I always let you control my anger.
Damn!
I'm not sure how much you're controlling for the priority.
Polis.
All right, and so it's not a police in Scotland,
it's the polis that are at the door,
like, oh, the polis out here.
You didn't really get,
it's quite common to get, like,
randomly spanked by the police,
so don't be too worried
as opposed to show up at your door.
I'm out of cherries.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
On the contrary, Riflin,
I'm sure I can spawn in a few more for you.
I'm sure there's a few first times I can have with you.
I'm sure, but don't you worry.
Don't you worry.
I thought you said polis, no.
Not polska.
Nie, nie polska.
Poka syski?
Is that why I'm not?
No polska today.
Hi, Mummy.
De-nailing here?
Oh, denial-ing here?
I edged too much.
And opted to ruin it.
Your audience is too hot and awful.
Oh, my God.
What?
How many?
Well, how long was your...
Oh, we need to deal.
I'll deal with, I'll deal with you
in the membership stream.
Thank you very much.
Can we pull a new audio for Patreon?
Um, there's a membership stream
that we're writing this week
for what you want,
but in November,
all Patreon contents
becomes what you guys
want me to write with you.
32 owns a house and a job,
and you stream the moment I go off work.
So having someone control me
after a tiny day
is an extraordinary feeling.
Oh, does it give you relief?
But in more ways than one.
Anyone want to buy Pokemon?
Collector's binder?
We got scum as with our binder, okay?
Yeah, we got scum as.
So many.
Sorry if this is a repeater
I got eaten.
Here's my gripper video.
Are you...
You sent a video of your feet moving?
As opposed to not moving.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm about to see your freaking feet on my...
I swear if you are...
And I open up this marshmallow.
I'm not opening up marshmallows on stream again.
Are you talking?
No, he's just moving his feet.
You're in your boxers!
Okay, I didn't see a pizza.
Wait, his feet are so pale.
What the fuck?
Why are they so pale?
Why are you white?
Okay, I think he's in his boxers.
Wait, who's in their boxers?
Hold on a minute.
Are you all in your boxers right now?
Wait a minute.
Who?
Who's not wearing anything right now?
She knows?
I mean, it's easier access.
Oh, you guys are wearing underwear.
Nope.
I'm in me joggers.
Broom, broom.
It's hot in here, okay?
I'm in bed, so yeah, boxers.
I'm wearing shorts.
The socks count.
You're only wearing socks?
They don't look cold.
I'm at work, fully clothed.
Oh, are you at work?
Ink yourself.
No!
No, don't, don't, don't, don't.
You're at work.
Pants to check.
I'm a grown man.
Why would I wear clothes on my own house?
Real, real through.
I don't have shit to do.
So hot.
Mmm, grab it up.
Power word.
Ink.
Easier to keep the jewels at a proper temperature.
Alone and naked.
I'm always on the commando grind.
Oh, you got the commando weapon on black ops?
Real.
Um.
Mmm.
Mummy, I'm nervous to say my age in chat,
although other reasons have said theirs.
But I'm 20 and yes, I'm letting you control my ink in America.
Oh, you're letting an older woman.
Call me a cougar.
An older woman?
Control your ink?
I'm walking in public so sadly, I'm modestly just terrible.
Caught me off guard, I'm wearing five pairs of pants.
Got you!
Got you in 4k.
A onesie for real, for real.
I've sucked on, does that count?
Something.
You spilled water on that bed.
Bed?
Who's bed?
This is called floor.
No bed here.
Below 20 and 30.
We're closing in on that real age boys.
Ooh.
Please do the foot cam script writing stream.
I have a major fantasy of being used as a chair and a foot sill.
Oh.
So that's your thing.
That's your special interest.
Oh, and you ignore me.
Just playing with that ball as you were yapping was killing me.
I'm sure the other refunds would enjoy it too.
Thank you, mommy.
You're too good.
Also CB, cognitive behavioural therapy is not punishment.
Kinkling.
More like you've got a name upgrade.
You're called kinkling.
Furnit year?
You want to be furnit year?
No bed, no hands for hanging.
Life is a lie.
What, you wanted my bed for the next one?
I mean, if you want, I can bring a mattress through for the next hand cam stream.
I don't see why not.
I can bring a mattress in if you want it.
Like, sure.
That's all you have to say.
Do it.
Treat me like an object.
Fuck no.
That's just vanilla stuff.
I'm kink-shing.
Older women are extremely hot.
I'd assume it's the same for women when older men are hot.
See, I go both ways.
I'm like fucking everything.
Gimme it all, please.
As a lurk.
As a lurk?
Hi, strongy.
All this lurker love is making me come out of the woodworks
and I'm a major lurker who doesn't even talk and chat.
Been lurking since debut.
Oh, hi.
We're almost at four months lurking on me from the shadows.
But I see.
And other girls, it's actually kind of bad
because whenever I become a member, I did it
when there was no stream, so you wouldn't read my name.
Oh, but that's like the best part about like becoming a member
because I'm not allowed to say your names in general.
Because that's feature, but there,
that's one of the unwritten VTuber rules,
to wrap around back to the singing.
That's like an unwritten VTuber rule.
I don't say your names in general, like I could,
but I don't because it's not possible.
But when you tip or become a member or stream snipe,
then that gives you the choice.
Although I feel a bit rough about the stream snipe one
because obviously for those who like to lurk,
I'm worried that you feel left out
because you don't want to show up on stream
because you're self-conscious.
But I'm hoping I can extract not only ink out of you
but some confidence as well.
So it would work out in the long run, you know?
Momay, a birth ASMR that ends in the reveal of Jenta next year.
I have no idea.
Like a real ninja.
That's okay.
I never like when VTuber say my name.
Why?
Beat for free just like that.
You're gonna love my monetization stream.
Sir?
There's a monetization stream
with your name written on it on this channel.
If you like VT.
Isn't that just for money purposes?
Like your only one worth can call your name if you pay me?
No.
Like if I start to try and say everyone's...
So I used to do this thing where I say good morning,
try and say everyone's name at roll call,
but it's not possible.
So I can only say it during the...
It's not like fuck you pay me, I'll say your name.
It's just like brain worms and all those issues that come up.
Fin don't fuck off!
No!
Nope!
I'm...
Nope.
We're not doing that.
You're done.
We're not...
We're not even touching that subject of our time football.
Mummy, what are your any opinions about armpits?
I think you should take a big inhale of mine,
memorize the sin and ink.
That's why I think about armpits.
It would cause brain worms if someone doesn't get their name called out when they're doing a roll.
Yeah, like I don't want brain worms either.
Don't shoot me!
I'm just a messenger!
Reeflings!
Twist that man's nipples right now.
Getting up on that reefling right now.
Show them...
Show them what a real twisty is all about.
Hi mummy, I'm also a denialing right now.
Can I ask for some words of encouragement?
I have until Saturday.
When's Saturday?
I'm on Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, Saturday.
What's that one?
Two, three, four, five.
Five more days, damn.
Sucks the suck, damnit.
Sucks the fucking suck.
Watch Thephilipod dom here?
I don't know, what would it...
It's healthy to lose gums with ink every stream.
I hope you find it.
Thank you, Gura, for that hit joke.
Yes, I will steal that.
Denialing, what would you say to that?
To encourage you?
Don't think about it.
But if you do think about it,
make sure you think really deep and hard about it.
Almost keep ramming the point over and over and over again in your head.
Where did my desktop audio display?
Something pleaded my desktop audio.
I don't know what it was.
Is someone streaming in the background?
Hi, mommie, I'm usually too tired to send in texts.
No, you don't have to.
But whenever you make content specifically for yourself,
I do like to send you something in return.
So don't worry if it seems like you don't want to send stuff.
I think most of us just wait for material.
That's fair.
No, that's true.
That's true.
That's definitely true.
I've been just lacking and lacking, unfortunately.
And that's like I fucked up when I made my Roblox account.
Literally have my first surname.
Yeah, definitely don't stream snipe if your legal name is on your social media.
That goes for anyone else listening out there.
Turn your name into 360 no scope now.
Do not use your legal name on any stuff.
Moment please.
These songs are good.
Hey, mommie, I need to go pee.
Can you pause the game?
I can't remember the VTuber's response to that.
I think that's a VTuber's name.
It's too late.
Just don't need the new honey you bought, you know.
Can we do an ASMR stream where we send our names on Maro and VTuber?
I did think about that for the Pokemon stream.
I was trying to take the feedback I got from the drawing stream,
the membership drawing one, where I gave him the gamer tag and stuff,
but people didn't like it, so I'm a bit hesitant.
Considering how you are advertised, I almost feel bad.
I haven't inked to me.
I just watched your streams.
You've never inked to me once?
Is it my accent?
There's not one thing that's made you want to ink.
I'm clearly failing my job.
I'm clearly a failure as a succubus.
No one?
You gave mummy brain worms, literally.
I've not said one thing that's tickled your pickle pink
until you stroke that shit raw.
Until you couldn't feel your thighs anymore?
What a failure of a fucking streamer I am.
Goddamn.
Sacrilege.
Mummy needs your ink to survive.
Girl, failure.
I can't believe it.
A face.
He's just a holy knight.
Don't take it personally.
Goddamn.
I'm the girl failure.
I can't even live up to those fucking expectations.
Shit.
Shocking.
Chong.
If that made you mad, you're not gonna like what I have to say.
No!
Wait, really?
Ah.
Don't take it to heart.
That fucking teasing game, that shit, the fuck?
Oh, you can't do that.
That's okay.
Um, there's a time and a place for that.
There it is.
I know what it is.
It's cause I'm not cute and funny, isn't it?
It's cause I'm not cute and funny.
You know what I think about that?
You don't have to be scared, I want this, please, for me.
That's it.
It's cause you want cute and funny, but I'm down here.
I'm all the way down here with my octaves.
I'm chilling down here with my octaves, all right?
Leave me and my deep voice alone.
I know you like the cute and funny.
I'm on to you.
Which one?
I don't think I've been again.
No, I'm on to you.
I sadly, I can't ink to you most of the time because of anti-depressants.
Oh, no, keep doing that.
Hold it.
All memes aside, all memes aside, all memes aside.
Do not stop taking, cause the thing about anti-depressants is
they take so long to build up in your system
if you stop taking them purely for the purpose of inking.
No, thank you.
Lollipops running.
Cunning cull.
Okay.
Hi, Yumi.
How's it going?
Cunning cull.
Fuck.
That's kind of good.
You like the dummy mommy voice?
What?
You mean you don't like the Ash Ketchum voice?
Ash.
I'm Ash Ketchum.
What do you mean you don't like my voice?
Um, you got class then?
Oh my god, you're in education?
How young?
Are you over 18?
I don't call out for people that are under 18.
Are you an-
Okay.
Monka is.
Please enjoy your class.
Goddamn.
What's the name plus twi-
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
You had me stressed in there.
I was like, you fucking middle school?
Why are you talking to me?
Why are you making content?
Change her back.
I want that voice that sounds like she's telling me all.
Oh, this one.
Right, okay.
It's Ash Ketchum.
Holy smokes.
I don't know what-
I don't know what American ranking system is.
Is middle school not like when you're 12 or something?
I have no idea.
University is a thing?
Well, it could use me for being uneducated
and not understanding the basic age ranges
of those who go into further education.
It could be at university.
College students can be 18 or 19.
Funny to put her on her toes though.
Did you just make a pun?
I hear, I hear, I hear.
You me said she put me on my toes.
This is my perfect team.
I don't like the toes pointing at-
Well, you don't have dexterity in your toes?
Like, can you not move them around
and do what you want with them?
I didn't mean to.
Oh my God.
Well, it was bloody good either way.
Nicely said.
I don't mind Ash Ketchum.
I have specific things though.
What?
You'd prefer Jesse instead?
What's the wrong briefling?
You don't like when mommy sounds like a Pokemon character?
Oh dear.
How you like that, boys?
Strony's toes are very powerful.
Can you do James?
Me off this right-
Wait, James.
To protect the world from devastation.
I can't go that deep.
Ma'am, please.
I'm in the kitchen.
Try and make dinner.
What's wrong?
Are you imagining me coming from behind you?
No.
Keep doing what you're doing.
I'm just going to stay behind you.
Press the real class in the kitchen.
James is higher than Jesse.
Wait, walk.
Protect the world from devastation.
To protect the world from devastation.
Me off this right?
Uh, I kind of fucking do.
Protect the world.
Protect the world from devastation.
Wait, no.
James, how?
I'm okay.
Please, I'm trying to click in.
Can you go ara ara?
Ara ara, and then in Jesse's voice.
Ara ara.
Have you been a good boy, little briefling?
Have you been making sure that mommy has perfect access to you?
Did you know if you stick your feet out from the blanket,
mommy's going to visit to talk you in?
The trolling James voice is our register's more than this one.
This is kind of thing.
How do you do it Valley though?
Oh my god, are you me?
It's been so long.
That's the best.
I go up right here.
That triggered my swallow reflex.
I'm playing a game of women's chills.
Young world craft.
Woman mathematical stood up.
Up two, three forward, up two, three forward.
It's been way too long.
We should like honestly catch the fuck up like seriously.
What? Why are you calling me a bimbo?
What are you talking about?
What does that word even mean?
You're so funny, briefling.
I like when you give me that expression on your face
like you're pitying me.
I don't know.
That's a car.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna imagine saying what?
No, I'm not a good boy.
In fact, I'm actually a bad boy that I became a woman.
What?
That's not every one.
Gayru voice on top.
Fifth, fifth gal in law.
Bimbos have big boobs.
I'm speechless.
I don't know what to say to that.
Um, you got me there.
You got me there.
I'm not gonna lie.
Fuck, I have no comeback.
Yeah, okay, I got to tip for that Jesse Aruara.
Pure gold.
I lost.
Oh, you liked it.
Thank you.
Literally I paused.
I was like, there's no recovery from that one.
Oh, I was like, oh, I can do this and this and this.
And I was like, well, actually the webcam's on right now.
If I go sideways, you're gonna see through me.
Um, so not as much as that happens.
Are you squinting me right now?
Mio's Oro Oro.
Strani is one of my favorite streamers.
Oh, yeah?
Thankfully, she doesn't know who I am since this is my out.
Gura Gura channel.in.
Okay, dude.
Thank you for the tip.
Gura, we love you, Gura.
I can't wait for your next thing.
I love your, your bucket, Callan.
Your gallon bucket of a comment.
That was really funny.
Peace.
I don't know how she can think on her feet like that.
Yeah.
I don't know how Gura could think so fast on her feet like that.
I don't get it because I'm just asking.
Um, I don't know how she did that, honestly.
I've lost gallons to you.
I hope you can go find it.
Gura's real.
She's a real good book.
Why is that whenever I come at hand?
I'm streaming my feet.
Honestly, you got me there.
Wrap it up.
The reefling called me out.
No, he's got a point.
Nope.
Hold on.
Let him speak.
He's got a point.
Um,
they're trying not like bimbos.
No, I'm flat-chested.
You may, you may.
There's no other way to explain this.
I am Patan.
Um, I have the smallest as well of all my gen mates.
Um, I am flat-chested.
No more feet on hand count streams?
Why are you lying?
I mean,
that's all you're getting.
Do you see head straight down this way?
There's nothing going on.
There's just little hills.
There's tiny little hills.
We're just chilling.
Chilling like a villain.
No, there's a little bit.
The hips coming.
A little bit.
I don't want to mess with the way I've come too much.
What time is it now?
Sorry.
Um,
Sheevee's boobs reattached.
Someone made a meme of Sheevee giving me her boobs
and I was like, who do you think ticked your boobs?
Stranny nose!
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Don't able to firmly grasp them.
Well, remember I do have a bra that's shaping them on,
by the way.
I have terrible news.
Thank you to Puckle Nation for the extended membership.
And the support.
I hope you enjoy your emotes.
They're soon coming.
20m.
Rip that shit off!
Free the boob.
I don't see any problems here.
Okay.
Don't say sorry.
I didn't mean it.
Oh, no, no, no.
Don't worry.
We're just teasing.
I'm teasing.
I'm teasing for a please and please don't overthink.
When you talk to me, you're wearing a brate.
Blasphemous.
I know.
Well, that's true.
If you're wearing a hammock and you said you were wearing a,
your boxerino.
So you're wearing a hammock.
Hi, mommy's feet.
Hello, Riefling.
It's nice to see you.
I'm talking to you through my feet.
Ta-da.
Sorry, I'm an innocent asylum right now.
Due to the fact that you can see my under feet.
To support what breast.
Right, steady on.
Right.
If there was no mild support, they'd start sagging and shit.
I don't know.
I don't know how science works.
Would you say it's not fair that guys can show their bitboops and women?
Oh, I get scared of men.
Like, whenever I watch a movie or a TV show and then that guy takes his shirt off,
I'm like, oh, I'm like, oh, right.
Okay.
Cause like, cause you're not allowed to see him another way, you know.
It's not expecting the ball squish.
Oh, I'm just having a bit.
I'm not, I'm just, I'm stimming on the ball right now.
I'm stimming so hard on your ball.
What do you feel about tattoos?
Knock yourself out.
Unfortunately, my mom instilled in shala.
She's instilled in me.
Didn't have any tattoos.
And I'm allowed piercings where they're not, well, I'm allowed.
I am an adult now, but when I was growing up,
I had an interest in getting like a tongue piercing and stuff.
But she said, don't get piercings where people can see them.
And I took that literally and I got my angel wings.
Um, yeah.
The sad ball, my single ball.
She's still one of those strong.
Making me hungry and hatred.
I want a neck tattoo, but that would kill my job.
Yeah, I'm gonna have to.
I'm afraid the world hasn't quite evolved past.
Oh my God.
Inc.
Now as much as the angel wings, um, yeah.
You hold on.
Let me, uh,
approve just a minute.
And you know what this is?
This is an angel wing.
This was in me.
It's no longer in me.
It was stolen from me by a shower.
That used to be a part of me, but unfortunately that ship
has sailed.
And no, I'm not gonna re-pierced.
You just have it.
Yeah, it ripped out like a month ago.
I, it tore off out of me, like out of my personal body.
It went, wee.
It was painful.
Yes, before you ask, it was excruciatingly painful, but
will we take out the other for symmetry?
Oh, I'm keeping it for now.
Um, did the nip rip off?
It reattached.
Um, because of the blood flow around the area,
um, it healed incredibly quickly,
which I kind of suspect.
But I'm a one-winged angel,
so I can kind of fly just a little bit,
not too much, but I can fly a little bit.
And you should take the other one out,
so you don't rip that one as well.
But because I only have one now,
my brain registers that I got only have one,
and I need to be careful.
She almost had a gripper nipple on her body.
What does that mean?
Oh, like, okay.
Shawnee, you need me to kiss it better.
Mmm.
But yeah, it's fine, honestly, it's fine.
Sephora?
What?
Evil?
Wait, you've both made a reference to this.
What is this?
What's Sephora?
What?
Is it Final Fantasy?
Oh, I've not played Final Fantasy, my apologies.
I thought Goofy was in Final Fantasy or something like that.
Sorry, I've not played Final Fantasy,
I've not played any of it.
Forgive me, okay, fake gamer,
only do it for male attention.
Sephora?
I've never seen the name before!
Stop typing names!
Like, you can't even be like,
oh, she said it wrong.
Goofy is in Kingdom Hearts.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, I'm getting Final Fantasy
in Kingdom's Heart messed up.
Sorry, I've not played either before you ask.
Sephora, right.
You've got Kingdom Hearts sometimes.
I'm sorry, like, they look the same or something,
I don't know.
I ain't played the genres yet.
The One-Winged Angel,
because you'll never guess what he is.
Cuddles?
I want to give you a womb tattoo,
but instead of a traditional one,
I want you to put my name on it
to show that you're my best friend.
Breeding pot, what the?
I don't think I should have read that one out loud.
Hmm.
Your technical type though.
Be honest.
I can't ink to you if you don't know
the Final Fantasy lore.
He did read that one out there.
Wait, I have to learn Final Fantasy lore?
Right.
Well, I'm Sephiroth, okay?
So, there you go.
How much more lore do you need
before you can base?
And base?
You're getting male attention and refling.
Ink mixed up?
I know.
Her internal thoughts are full of like,
more sane refling.
It's like,
it's like Dresda, but a femboy?
What?
Have we got femboy?
Are we fighting more femboys?
We just bought one in Elden Ring there.
Hmm.
That's pretty fucking hot.
I'm a little reminded though.
Eh, not sure if message got filtered.
Sorry if it's a repair.
Insert glasses, copy past that mummy.
I have a thing for nerdy girls with glasses.
Since you have glasses,
can you pin some on your model?
Just for fun.
Can you pull and see the reasons why you look like that?
Oh no!
Yeah.
Reeflin.
A reeflin.
Are you fucking Gamblin?
I mean, I'll give it a like and a heart,
but don't fucking Gamba.
Doin'.
I just gambled on Pokemon cards and look what I get.
Energies and repeats for a century.
Wait, you can't see that tile there.
Hold on, I'm bringing it up.
Literally, look all these repeats.
Repeats, repeats, repeats.
Some of them I had multiple.
They showed up more than once.
Like, you're Gamblin?
This is a job.
You're gonna lose, the house always wins.
Like, literally, I just had to work with Gamblin.
If you ignore the specials,
but the specials were guaranteed anyway,
you just touch them with your feet,
you gain 100% more value at once.
Gamblin for fun is fine,
but throwing money at it is expensive all day.
That's not Gamblin, that's RNG on the pack.
Gamblin is more Gamblin.
No more Gamblin, I'm having this.
What if I'm the house?
Get it twisted, you will win big.
Whoa, that is a reference
to hardly anyone's gonna get.
Get it twisted.
Wow, that's a good reference.
I don't like Coke.
I don't do Coke, I drink Coke.
He has luck from strongy believing him.
Someone please fall out New Vega.
What, Gamble?
You can Gamble and fall out New Vega?
Oh, Gamblers stop when they're about to win big.
So yeah, you're gonna turn the reflins into addicts.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Let's go Gamblin.
Aw, dang it.
Mummy dad permission to go pee?
No, hold it for five minutes.
What, you can't last another five minutes?
Really?
Hold it for five minutes.
You can stay a little time on your phone, it's fine.
If you're gonna ask for permission,
you're gonna have to wait.
Uh, Mummy, I really appreciate how you make time for us,
even when you should be working.
Even if it's procrastination,
glad we entertain and give you back a little bit of what you just said.
No, that's what I was trying to say before I got distracted.
Imagine helping strongy by giving her 100k for the tip.
No, don't give me that kind of money, are you stone?
I wouldn't even know what to do with it.
Typical nation, thank you for the tip.
No, don't give me this kind of money.
Don't do that, as I said, for my one year anniversary,
I'm gonna purchase the KU100 microphone.
It's gonna be out of my money, I'm happy to do that.
I wanna experiment with that mic,
and say I'm a real ace, Mars, wink, wink,
even though I don't have the setup at all enabled for it.
No, don't do that, don't give me that kind of money.
Wrap it up.
That's too much money for one person to have.
A multiverse?
I don't think so.
Too much money for one person to have.
A multiverse, honestly.
Mommy, you've been playing with the weebaw for like 10 minutes.
I mean, I can touch it too, so like...
You can get down here if you like.
Or does that make it weirder?
I don't know, 10 of the weirds.
Supply in.
You want me to sit on it?
I don't even know what's...
Is it gonna...
If it explodes everywhere, you're fucking cleaning this up.
Do you understand reefling?
If this explodes, you are cleaning up.
All the little balls are about to go everywhere.
Hold on.
Oh.
I can't see it squishing out.
Just approve.
Oh, sorry, my duplicate.
Someone, please think of the health of my duplicate part.
Thank you, thank you.
Can you see it?
It's not...
Oh, there's one more card, hold on.
If this freaking breaks...
I'm gonna be so mad.
It's not really...
Alleycraft?
It looks like a tail, honestly.
It looks like a weird marshmallow tail.
Mami, you're gonna make that reeflings ball explode, honestly.
Oh, excuse me, I'm just standing up.
Oh, excuse me.
That's terrible.
Mami, did you know those balls are wet inside?
So, last time I'm saying the things,
well, you're cleaning up a cinematic universe.
It's gonna go hard, honestly.
She's too good.
So, you're gonna buy another one then.
Another ball?
What, you want me to have two balls to play with on stream?
I never thought that far ahead, but that makes sense.
Typical nation thing for the set.
Someone said, like,
oh, I want to try and repay you for the thingy.
No, you don't understand.
I'm in debt to you.
Do you understand, like, how happy I am and how fulfilled I am
and, like, just how amazing it is to, like, be with you, like, reefling?
Like, I don't know how to say it.
Like, you're not in debt to me.
You don't have to show me any kindness.
You don't need XYZ, Elemental P, anything like that.
I'm just fucking happy to be here.
That is the bottom line.
And the truth is, I'll never be able to repay you for anything like that, you know?
So don't be, uh, yeah.
I think you're now tapped for more time than you've spent.
Opening car, I'm sorry.
I've yapped, yeah.
Sorry, I can't sub.
No, it's not like that.
You don't have to.
Like, you don't have to.
That's why I stream every single day.
Like, even though I do membership streams,
it's not like one day I do a membership stream
and no stream on that day.
Like, no, I do like a regular, schmagular stream.
And then, like, because it's not like that.
Like, don't think it's like that.
Don't, don't get it twisted.
What a strongy stream without a good app.
One PP touch on the debt.
It's paid.
I either can.
I'm currently, no, you don't have to.
Like, don't think like that.
My prediction for 5-0 stream.
He's a tenner for sitting on your ball.
Did he deserve that?
Did it hurt?
But did it hurt good?
Thank you, basically, Liz, for the tip.
My predictions for a 5-hour stream.
What are we at?
How long?
It was 3 hours 44 minutes ago.
The fuck?
Who else has a shit ton of money
to throw this woman in now?
Oh my gosh.
Well, how about we both agree that it goes both ways?
How much for socks off?
No, don't give me money for that.
I'm not sure.
I've still got my pedicure on my feet
and I don't like how it looks,
so I don't like showing my feet right now.
Typical nation, thank you for the tip.
Spidey, keep your money.
Don't fucking give me money.
Right, okay, okay, okay.
I'll redirect into Marisa.
Let's wrap up like a protection layer.
Well, I'll wrap it up, okay?
Right, I'm gonna redirect into damn it, I don't...
Unless Shibi is streaming.
Shibi, technically, what?
Should be up in...
Should Shibi be up in 10 minutes?
Am I going mental?
No, she doesn't have her waiting room.
So is Emi going waiting room's up?
Is this being cancelled?
I guess it's been cancelled.
Oh, no, Emi can't stream anyway.
Dumbass, Emi can't stream.
That's why the fucking thing can't be cancelled.
Dumbass, dumbass.
Okay, I'm gonna...
No, stop giving me money, I'm going.
So my money, okay.
No, Kalker, thank you for the tip.
Yep.
No, Emi, who?
Emi, B-Soup, sorry that you didn't recognize the name.
Okay, sorry you didn't recognize the name.
Shibi has the members.
Marisa is the only one that's been public.
Okay, I'll redirect into them.
Okay, look at this.
This is payment-along.
I'm just telling you that everything is okay
while I give you hugs and headpats.
Oh, that's actually easy.
Thank you for the donation.
Right, no more fucking money.
Stop it, you're stalling me.
And I don't want to stall for money.
It makes me uncomfortable.
Twenty seconds, I really need to wee.
Okay, go pee.
Don't read this stream.
I'm sorry if this comes off as angry.
Okay.
True.
Barbecue pulled pork sandwiches or burgers.
What do you want for dinner?
Are you making me food?
Oh my gosh.
What would you look?
Beef or pork?
I would say burgers
because you can put lettuce on it and cheese.
I like lettuce and burgers because it's a nice crunch.
It's so good.
That reef one had some shit to say.
Sorry, quietly.
Jimmy, B-Soup,
Stronathan, Cthulhu, Cthulhu?
Cthulhu.
Oh, Cthulhu.
That's not bad.
Love you, Stron.
I love you too, reef one.
Thank you for the stream.
No, thank you for the stream.
I apologize for yapping
when this was supposed to be a handcam.
It's literally just my feet kicking a ball around.
But literally, we're playing footy.
Strony, you should tell me what to edge to later.
Me, bitch.
I have like three audios on the alt square.
Go, listen to them again and tell me you don't like that shit.
And it's a nice, yeah.
But I do enjoy getting that.
Love you, mommie.
So I'm getting distracted.
Right, I'm going.
I'm going to work.
Right, what do you want me to do before?
Do you want to like a little dance?
Or do we pretend that this is...
I don't know.
What would you like me to do before we go?
Before we wrap it up?
Come and walk again.
Here, here.
I'm Michael Jackson.
I touch little things.
Who said that?
That's wrong.
How many nostrils does Michael Jackson have?
Brick down there.
Put it down there.
Oh, you can see me thrusting.
You put your hands on your hips.
Remove the thoughts and take the...
I'm not ruining the thoughts.
My feet size, big monster feet.
All right, hold on.
Are you guys going to put Pokemon cards?
Are you going to put Pokemon cards at home?
Can you use that Pokemon card?
Like, if I do it from my heel there,
I'm like two Pokemon cards.
And a bit more, like a third Pokemon card comes into it.
Just a jump to the top.
Can you join the ace monster?
Ooh, you're in for a treat tomorrow.
Okay.
Oh no, my fucking...
Oh, my phone's dying.
Right, wrap it up.
My phone's dead.
Wrap it up.
The fucking trash is dead.
The track is gone.
Reeflings, bedtime.
Bedtime, right.
Everyone go to bed.
Go to sleep.
Do you have a banana for scale?
The real Pokemon...
The real measurements are Pokemon.
Forget kilometers.
Forget the other unit of measurement.
Yards?
Oh god, do you see your...
No, you can't see your feet are three yards long.
That doesn't make any sense.
Truly not.
Mommy's falling to sleep on us.
No.
It's time to tuck you into bed.
After I give you the good suck.
Are you gonna be okay?
Now strip off and bounce on that peach on my tentacle.
I love reading your marshmallows.
Seriously.
Yours are so out of pocket.
Like the start of the marshmallow.
The reason why I read that sentence out loud.
Strony, you're so sweet.
You're sweet too, Reefling.
The love is completely mutual.
Now strip off and bounce that peach on my tentacle.
Yeah, my track is down.
Who said that?
Who stole my idea?
Give it back.
Those five minutes almost made me pee my jeans.
Then don't ask for permission again.
Because I'm gonna make you good.
Okay.
You get spanking.
Reef, I love you lot.
I apologize that this hand cam stream turned into a foot cam.
I would say I'm sorry.
But am I?
No.
I give you the content that you do not ask for nor want.
And you must be thankful for it.
You will be grateful for what I provide.
Even though you did not request it at all.
At all.
Beat or just the hands of the man.
That's true.
I mean you need to bounce on my feet.
Okay, right, right.
I love you little Reeflings.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna redirect into Mercy's karaoke.
It will be unarchived.
Just as a heads up because of copyright issues as always.
YouTube ruins it.
Thank you everyone for hanging.
And for chilling.
And binchini.
Don't you want binchini?
Right on my nose.
Okay, you're done.
Please look after yourselves.
Tomorrow we are getting up to.
Let's find out what we're getting up to tomorrow.
We are playing with Portal 2.
With Sheevee who has never played the game before.
So don't be a stinker then.
I can never remember the last few puzzles.
They get a bit too advanced for my brain.
But thank you so so much.
I will see you tomorrow for the shaggagagans.
Let me and Sheepsters we'll be up to.
And we're gonna see if we can finish it in one go.
I warned her it's five hours long.
But I might be able to remember the puzzles.
I'm gonna give her a blast with it.
But we can almost come back to it later if she gets the time.
It's not a problem.
Not a problem.
And I know I know these things, okay.
All right I love you lots I'll see you tomorrow please.
Remember to hydrate.
Hydrate.
Remember to rest.
Remember to look after yourself.
Remember to wash behind your ears and your belly button.
And scrub yourself down with a flannel.
And remember to eat and be kind to yourself.
Okay.
And remember you're still being denied.
But you enjoy mercy.
Okay.
When she comes up she's coming up soon.
But you put you put you.
That's supposed to be the sound effects from Brian.
But I don't have the thing plugged in.
See you later alligator.
In a wild crocodile.
And then I'll give you kisses for mimicry.
I think there was nine packs.
One clue.
We want one.
One, two, three, four, seven, eight, nine.
Nine packs.
Okay nine packs.
Bye bye.
See you tomorrow.
I kissed you.
Bye bye.